[Musique]
monsieur l'ambassadeur bonsoir bonsoir
vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne un terrain qui s'appelle think ur
view monsieur l'ambassadeur loucher est
ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
alors je m'appelle la louche alliés
ambassadeur de chine en france je suis
arrivé il y a plus deux ans plus
précisément à la fin du mois de juillet
2019 et
j'aime beaucoup la france
donc malheureusement à cause de la
pandémie j'ai pas
voyagé beaucoup dans le pays mais quand
même j'ai fait d'été pacs mots et j'ai
constaté les paysages de différentes
régions de la france et j'aime beaucoup
la culture et
la cuisine aussi france
monsieur l'ambassadeur tout d'abord
avant de commencer 7,1 cette interview
on tenait
à vous remercier du moins remercie votre
équipe technique pour sa précision et sa
réactivité et sur le fait que 1 ils nous
ont pas demandé des questions avant de
vous êtes venu sans rien à voir vous
êtes venu à l'heure sans savoir à quelle
sauce vous allez être mangés et règne
pour ça mes respects
donc vous ne parliez de vous n'avez pas
trop voyager en france mais vous aimiez
la cuisine c'est quoi votre plat préféré
français histoire de se détendre un peu
avant de commencer les plats qu'est-ce
que vous avez goûté escargots huîtres le
litre est ce que vous savez pourquoi
mange des escargots et des huîtres en
france pourquoi parce que nous le peuple
français on a connu la famine
et donc on s'est mis à manger des choses
tôt ce soir seule chose difficile à
manger au départ c'est pour ça que
mangent les escargots et comme enjeu des
huîtres
quoi d'autre vous avez mangé quoi
d'autre
les plâtres et exquise
fait par les grands chefs
dans les rues cependant les restaurants
tous sortent les boeufs les que le
canard comme ça et la foire bien sûr qui
est très connu en chine
mais ce que vous avez dit je me souviens
c'est un peu un peu comme la chine parce
que dans le dans l'antiquité dans les
histoires dans les temps très anciens
en chine et il y avait souvent des
familles donc effectivement les chinois
mangent presque tout
même le serpent
les français ne mangent pas sa place ici
bien préparé sa passant c'est un peu
comme le pangolin il faut que ce soit
bien préparé la maintenance est pas
encore là je pense que très peu parce
que c'est interdit peuget en principe
pas parce que ce sont des animaux
sauvages le gouvernement chinois ont des
lois et règlement pour interdire
comment dire la transaction
illégale illicite
vous vous a fait venir et vous avez
accepté notre proposition pourquoi vous
avez accepté de venir nous voir oui je
pense que la communiste la communication
est
la meilleure façon
de faire bien connaître les différents
peuples puisque je suis ambassadeur de
chine en france
j'ai la mission de présenter la chine de
raconter l'histoire de la chine au
peuple français et c'est pourquoi je
saisi toutes
les occasions pour
pour me présenter au public français
pour faire la communication avec
l'opinion publique ici
avant de rentrer dans des détails
j'aimerais mieux vous connaître
papa il faisait quoi maman elle faisait
quoi mes parents
so médecins prêts mais mon père est déjà
est déjà mort il ya il ya plusieurs
années
et donc ma mère est déjà en retraite
depuis depuis presque 20 ans brison elle
est très très bien
les enfants oui j'ai un enfant j'ai un
quart sont la chance
il y travaille déjà maintenant un temps
une compagnie chinoise d'aviation
îles et îlots chine au matin
vous m'avez fait beaucoup travailler et
c'est difficile de suivre les chinois en
termes de travail ce que vous êtes des
brutes et il y reçoit je suis tombé sur
un rapport de 650 pages
j'ai lu gelé jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
pour vous vous avez tous lu j'ai tout le
656 150 pages c'est difficile si si ça
se lit très bien ça se lit très vite
cessé d'ailleurs c'était moi c'était
mieux fais tu le rapport qui a été fait
sur les russes j'ai trouvé que le
rapport sur y c'était un peu bâclé sur
certains certains détails autant ce
rapport là il est très difficile très
sourd c est ce que vous l'avez lu
à vrai dire j'ai pas lu j'ai pas le
temps de tout lui de tout lire mes
collègues
ont lu
quoi une partie peut être parce que nos
rapports vient de sortir
mais on a on à l'huile et l'irsn
inserm et om
mais il était dé presse des journaux ont
fait là le reportage
et ils ont ils ont fait une présentation
même très en détail
ouais
mes collègues ondulent les reportages et
on a remarqué que
le ton de ce rapport n'est pas très
positif sur la chine n'a pas ce pays
il pense que
la chine est il en train de faire une
propagande soit soi-disant propagande la
désinformation
notre communication avec
les français sont tous pour
but de
faire des
propagandes pour faire des menaces je
pense que c'est pas c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai et effectivement ils ont
utilisé beaucoup de
d comment dire de famous
raconté qu'elle ja lesquelles quel type
de faits que nous ils ont raconté par
exemple il dit ils disent que
l'ambassade de chine à embaucher des
étudiants chinois des ressources
ressortissants chinois
ici pour faire pour
se servir pour sert à troll sur internet
et est diffusée quoi l'aider informatio
du gouvernement chinois s'est passé mais
c'est pas vrai alors je vois de quel
parti vous faites référence ils font ils
font une étude ils disent qu'il ya
deux millions de troll maison et et
vingt et vingt et vingt millions troll
20 millions de troll de
de contractuels qui viennent
épisodiquement pour pour pousser la
vision chinoise du parti communiste sur
les réseaux sociaux est ce que c'est
vrai c'est pas vrai j'adore sortie
l'organigramme fait 2 2 2 où ils sont
basés qui les commandent comment il son
pays quel est le tarif du post
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à ça
c'est à elle leur répond je vais je vais
je veux demander
d'où vient ces chiffres là est-ce qu'ils
ont la preuve pour dire que le
gouvernement chinois a empoché de thé me
diot des dizaines de medio de troll pour
aider à atif usées
la vision du gouvernement chinois
effectivement nous avons beaucoup de
ressortissants dans le monde entier
n'est ce pas ce sont des chinois ils
aiment leur patrie et on voit maintenant
dans le monde surtout dans le monde
occidental
la chine a été beaucoup
stigmatisée a diffamé par la presse et
surtout la presse occidentale et quel
type de diffamation quel type de menaces
mais par par exemple sur sur
le problème de la lutte contre
l'épidémie de convives 19 ou connaissez
certainement il y a beaucoup de
mensonges là dessus sur la face aux eau
de toutes parts de quoi de de notre côté
de votre côté de tous les côtés ya des
mensonges
les mensonges de là dans la presse
occidentale sur la chine
au sujet du traitement de la cop vite il
ya
toutes sortes par exemple l'origine du
virus déçoit tout récemment les
américains même utilisent leurs agences
d'enseignés moi ou pour retrouver les
preuves
pour prouver que ces
laboratoires
laboratoire avocat qui a diffusé le
virus à la fin ils n'ont pas ou ils
n'ont pas eu un ancien maire de guan
maire-adjoint de one way
donc je connais bien
si vous êtes si comme en tant que
chinois
il sera certainement très indignée de
ces mensonges là donc pour les ressentis
s'en lèche des étudiants chinois à
l'étranger ils ont le sentiment bien
l'instant pts
pour réagir pour
pour comment dire
dire un
pour plaider pour aider leur patrie on
va on va revenir sur le court des virus
un peu plus tard on va terminer sur le
rapport
quand je les ai vus je me suis dit là
proclame première réflexion j'ai eu
c'est excusez moi de vous le dire je dis
les chinois et sont forts ils
sont très très très très très très fort
parce que ce qui est marqué dans ce
rapport c'est la quintessence même de
tout ce qui se fait pour contrôler de la
population contrôle des connaissances
infiltration et j'en passe et des
meilleurs
avec en plus cette petite particularité
chinoise
qui est de faire ça d'une façon très
besogneuse et très organisés et ensuite
la deuxième chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit c'est qu'est ce qu'on a fait
nous les occidentaux
pour vous mettre dans un état pareil
c'est à dire que quand je lis le rapport
sa détaille
méthodiquement le fonctionnement du
parti communiste de sa stratégie des
opérations qui peuvent entamer des
réseaux qui peuvent tisser
on va laisser le bénéfice du doute à ce
rapport et je vais vous poser des
questions sur comment
si c'est vrai comment vous en êtes
arrivé à vous victimiser vous protéger
de tels de cette façon là c'est du fait
que les anglais vous ont transformé en
junkie ya cent ans c'est une rancoeur
c'est une peur qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est de cette façon
des tellement
protectionnistes de ne parler que à des
gens qui ne vous critique pas soit vous
êtes avec nous soit vous êtes contre eux
contre nous c'était la rhétorique de
george bush
et ça moi en tant qu'occidental me
tournon
de bon matin en regardant mes frères
vivent de l'autre côté du monde
je me dis mais pourquoi ils sont partis
en mode guerrier pareil on fait toujours
le parallèle avec la communication
chinoise de loups guerrier comment vous
en êtes arrivé à st
en effet
je ne suis pas d'accord que alors c'est
le gouvernement chinois ou bien le parti
communiste chinois qui a qui ont
organisé spécialement des mouvements
pour comme comme levier le rapport
un mouvement de
désinformation laisse pas
la chine la foule des visas de contrôle
diversité un contrôle des journalistes
non c'est pas le contrôle
bien sûr la chine est très bien
organisée
n'est ce pas c'est notre force
mais cette organisation s'est pas
pauvres pour faire
l'enfance
l'offensif
on reste toujours en défensif la chine
ne provoque n'attaque jamais
les autres oui c'est toujours que la
chine qui se trouve
attaqué
provoquer que nous faisons la défense
nous ripostons seulement vous pouvez
trouver ce cas tu entends tous les
toutes les situations
qu'il soit dans la situation derrière de
lakovic 19 de là
médiatisation du problème dans du
cimetière n'est ce pas ou bien deux
de la question de taiwan la chine en
reste toujours en défensive mais on a le
droit de faire la défensive puisque
quand la chine étant défensif est ce que
la chine etc ou toujours les voies qui
pourraient lui dira peut-être que c'est
le mauvais chemin
le mauvais chemin notre approche oui les
occidentaux nous nous disent toujours
vous ne devez pas faire comme ça c'est
pas diplomatique ses looks et rouillée
je peux vous poser une question entre
mai mais on ne fait pas comme ça on doit
commencer on reste muet oui face aux
attaques face aux stigmatisations
alors si on reste muet
la chine sera comme ce que tu écris ou
bien dépeint la presse occidentale alors
d'image dans la presse occidentale sic
de la chine c'est quoi c'est un des mots
c'est un
criminel
qui a causé
le
la crise ou bien de la pandémie
en effet c'est la chine qui est la
première à tirer la larme l'alertent de
la pandémie n'est ce pas à la fin de
l'année 2019 on a on a détecté
la parution du virus on a tout de suite
communiqué l' oms donc
je vous coupe
sur sur la la communication autour de
l'épidémie clairement les pouvoirs
occidentaux ont mis un peu la
responsabilité de l'alertent sur vous
parce qu il ait pas de la veille correct
nous on avait des gens chez vous qui
nous tenait au courant heure par heure
de tout votre dispositif de sécurité
heure par heure on savait qu'elle était
le checkpoint donc elle rue à ouman
qu'elle porte vous aviez soudés pour
empêcher les gens de sortir de chez eux
on avait envoyé des gens dans les
quartiers pauvres de one ce qui
d'ailleurs a été le plus difficile pour
nous c'est d'aller visiter les quartiers
pauvres de one pour savoir comment vous
contrôler l'épidémie dans les quartiers
populaires
on est l'information donc si nous on
avait eu de viande à voir s'ils
investissent correctement nos impôts par
contre moi je vous dis je vous pose la
question
vous parlez vous parlez de duke au vide
pourquoi on peut pas les faire une
enquête chez vous pourquoi il ya des
bases de données de virus
à caractère universitaire qui ont été
enlevés de l'internet
ce genre ce genre de petits détails on
dit toujours
nous en france le diable se cache dans
les détails
est-ce que vous pouvez comprendre
l'opinion publique sur le fait que vous
revendiquez une transparence
mais que derrière
vous avez pas envie qu'ils n'enquêtent
chez vous i fo a tout à fait faux la
chine a déjà invité à deux reprises
l'équipe d'experts de la ms a visité la
chine qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit ils ont
dit qu'il n'avait pas de marge de
manoeuvre ils ont dix et neuf ils ont vu
tout ce qu'ils veulent voir ils ont
rencontré tous ceux qui le veut
rencontrer voir
ce saut c'est ce que disent les experts
de la messe
mais le reportage
de la presse occidentale ne dit jamais
ça ils ne disent pas la vérité sur la
chine
c'est pourquoi vous avez l'impression
que la chine ne permet pas le rsa a
enquêté la chine c'est faux nous avons
déjà invité deux fois donc l'équipe hôte
experts de la messe à visiter vous rend
à visiter l'observateur avouera avoir
toutes les données fournies par la chine
oui même si même les premiers donné
deux des huit russe mais bien sûr il y a
détonné qui ne peut pas sortir de la
chine à cause de la protection des prix
de la vie privée c'est dans votre pays
c'est comme ça c'était des données qui
étaient déjà en ligne qui étaient
consultables par tous nous devrons alors
vous pouvez consulter vous pouvez
consulter ces données puisqu'ils sont
déjà en lice on dit que la chine cache
encore non non non on ne cache rien si
ce n'est de l'autre côté on voit
maintenant que
effectivement avant la parution du virus
pour la première fois en chine à la fin
de 2019
effectivement
d'après la recherche scientifique après
les virus sont déjà
existent existe déjà dans les pays
amérique des états unis dans les pays
européens
dans la deuxième moitié de l'année 2019
mais pourquoi on y on ne va pas dans ces
pays là pour faire la recherche
scientifique
il ya des preuves il dit
tk prom prime primaire aux états unis
n'ont rien à voir avec la chine parce
que les gens qui ont été contaminés
n'ont jamais voyagé en chine
mais au mois de juillet d'où septembre
2019 il ya pour déjà des cas contaminés
mais pourquoi on ne fait pas la
recherche là bas on ne fait pas l'anc
est ce là bas
commençons par faire une enquête en
chine on a déjà fait l enquête sans fil
sera déjà fait cette fois cette fameuse
base de données qui étaient disponibles
pour les chercheurs pourquoi elle était
retirée du net
quelle belle qu'elle adresse de données
avec on va dire le dictionnaire des
virus étudient dans votre ventre je
pense à je ne sais pas le détail a
peut-être il ya des problèmes techniques
ce que je sais par exemple les
scientifiques chinois ont envoyé ont
posté étonné sur un site
américains et on a retiré mais on a
rohff reposter il ya des étés et des
problèmes techniques tout le monde le
comprend les scientifiques ne
comprennent
les scientifiques ne les comprennent
mais c'est la presse qui ont déformé ça
quand il faut le reportage
en effet pour les scientifiques eux
c'est pas c'est pas un prof un problème
grave mais ce sont les journalistes qui
ont exagéré
en ce qui concerne le laboratoire au sia
tombe bien moi je suis pas journaliste
ouais c'est pourquoi je vous ai pts
joseph public à la de la vérité alors
c'est pas comme le racontent les
journalistes c'est peut-être votre
vérité mais moi j'ai enquêté vous avez
enquêté et moi j'ai j'ai des gens chez
vous
oui j'ai des gens qui me tiennent au
courant de ce qui se passe est ce que
vous avez consulté les scientifiques
chinois ch je vous pose la question est
ce que ça peut potentiellement être un
risque industriel un dommage collatéral
un accident industriel
admettons que le laboratoire p3 qui
avait déjà été pris la main dans le sac
pendant des années à recycler ces
animaux de laboratoire pas très
correctement est ce que ça peut être
une bourde d'un technicien de
laboratoire comme ça arrive souvent et
est ce que
ces quelques petites personnes qui
auraient masqué sa et est ce que
peut-être c'est toujours le récit de la
presse occidentale
c'est ça bah je ne suis pas scientifique
à je ne connais pas à vrai dire
qu'est ce que c'était quoi comme
spécialisé spécialisation vos parents il
était pédiatre gastro entérologue
chirurgien au choix ils ne sont pas dans
ce domaine des eaux pas tarder c'est
normal ils sont quel domaine des îles
son temps dans la comment dire la sanie
le
la 110 en santé publique ouais c'est pas
à vivre leurs huîtres au logis alors ça
tombe bien parce que moi dans ma famille
j'ai un super grand virologues j'avais
un grand super ok qui était un des
précurseurs sur la maladie de lyme la
piroplasmose shalom ouais donc et j'ai
la chance aussi d'un connaître beaucoup
beaucoup médecin
pas des petits médecins locaux ont des
gens qui on est créé sos mains des gens
qui ont monté des département de
virologie de maladies infectieuses des
pointures de classe internationale je
leur ai posé la question ils m'ont mise
sur quelques pistes et on ne comprend
pas
pourquoi vous faisait de la recherche
sur le gain de fonction sur les
coronavirus en chine
d'après ce que je sais à ce ne sont pas
les scientifiques chinois qu'il faut la
recherche du camp de fonction du virus
ce sont 7 ce sont des scientifiques
américains il y a un grand ce grand
scientifique qui s'appelle eric paris
qu'un en grande scientifique virologiste
américain parie qu il s'appelle y
travaille à l'université de la
calandre est fou experts venant carolina
de l'état
caroline du nord il a en laboratoire at
ans dans cette université il a fait
cette recherche de gains de fonction
depuis depuis longtemps il est le
premier scientifique à réussir à changer
le virus mais cette recherche a été fait
dans son la parole dans son laboratoire
à l'université de caroline du nord c'est
pas en chine
bien sûr il y a eu une scientifique
chinoise qui s'appelle soutient guy
dufour me tais tu es virus
et des éléments aux biens des gens dit
you n'est ce pas mais elle n'a pas fait
la recherche c'est ce scientifique
américain qu'il a fait mais aux états
unis c'est par hocine il s'agit ça peut
pas arriver en chine où ça peut pas
arriver en chine
c'est leurs résultats leurs résultats de
recherche et izon déjà faire la demande
de brevet mais personne d'autre ne peut
pas utiliser son résultat sans son
approbation
sans son permis
revenons à notre rapport
dites moi moi quand je les ai vus
ça m'a fait un peu peur quand même parce
que 6ème vous regardez la table des
matières je me suis dit ça m'étonnerait
pas de vous quand même c'est la
quintessence même de ce qu'il faut faire
sur les réseaux pour contrôler une
population
c'est de lire ça je me suis dit ces gens
sont fous ils sont en train de mettre à
disposition à l'ensemble des partis
politiques du monde une méthode qui a
l'air de fonctionner
quand on vous présente la chine comme ça
comme faisant passer les russes pour des
écoliers en terme de propagande sur les
réseaux
ça vous fait quoi
ça vous met sur la défensive
vous pouvez l'expliquer ok
donc c'est pas le contrôle
on connaissait via l'internet s'ils ont
noté dans un site effectivement vous
êtes déjà vu mais par qui par n'importe
qui on connaissait bien
ce sont les états unis qui est le plus
grand superviseur
sur internet le plus gros s'y perd
attaque du soul zouk tout craché ce que
vous venez de me dire oh ça c'est du sud
où tout craché sauzeau oui quand vous
prétendre que vous êtes faibles alors
que vous êtes français c'est pas faible
ce que je veux dire c'est que dans le
monde
d'internet
on peut dire que havre est effectivement
on n'a pas de vie privée si vous êtes
dié surligne vous est supervisé par
quelqu'un
supervisé par tout le monde pas tout le
monde paris - les russes les américains
surtout vers les américains parce que
les américains ont eu ce moyen ils sont
de plus avancés les à main et en os le
cas femmes ils ont le plus fort en chine
effectivement les internautes se sont
très très dit prêt à venir si ou roter
dans les vingt ans on peut et émis
toutes sortes opinion
way à vrai dire vous sinon en chine on
dit que il y à des intellectuels
des intellectuels public
en chinois ça s'appelle conques jeu
qu'est ce que c'est ces intellectuels
public c'est ce qu'ils émettent toujours
des opinions
contraires
au gouvernement à la position du
gouvernement je fais ça toute la journée
motion france bazzo week c'est en chine
c'est toute la journée aussi il n'a pas
d'avenir en chine qu'en fin - macron
même si les ligaments vaincrons il veut
pas m'envoyer la police ou ailleurs en
france les internautes quand vous aimez
des opinions on devait respecter
observer les lois on ne devait pas
contrevenir à la loi à la constitution
et dans les écoles françaises il y a
lancé les morts de la valeur
républicaine n'est ce pas ça c'était
avant
ces bâtiments maintenant les semenciers
n'est pas les valeurs oui accusant le
président emmanuel macron dit qu' il
faut enseigner il faut
commander à enseigner les valeurs
républicaines est-ce que chez vous j'ai
le droit de critiquer votre leadership
chinois critiquer quoi qui si jean ping
voici si j'ai envie de dire
je ne peux me permettrait de ne pas être
vulgaire mais si je veux dire en france
que mon président est un coup cet hiver
je lisais la différence de culture et s
consignes jeunes heureux de faire ça
en chine la respecte la personne les
individus ouais j'en dis c'est la
différence des cultures occidentales et
orientales où pouvait être si direct
ostensible en chine ne sais pas c'est
pas notre habitude c'est pas de notre
culture comprenez ou pas
comprendre quoi les gens qui sont
directes je vous pose une question est
ce que moi je comprends rescue mange
comme shaw respecte toujours les les
différentes cultures les différentes
civilisations au nadal vient jamais dans
l'est dans les affaires intérieures des
autres c'est pas très vrai ça
c'est pas très vrai ouais c'est votre
opinion non je
démontre encore la différence tu as tu
que tu rentres no2
accordons-nous sur ce désaccord je vous
donne un exemple nous la france on a la
nouvelle calédonie connaissait la
nouvelle calédonie et il magnifie
aimerait promis mais magnifique pas si
petit que ça l'est d'ailleurs
dans le rapport en question on dit que
vous faites de l'ingérence qu'on
nouvelle calédonie et que vous
sponsorisés que vous stimuler les
mouvements indépendantistes c'est vrai
c'est pas vrai qu'ils vous non non mais
pas vous le parti communiste non or on
assimile pas le mouvement
indépendantiste en nouvelle calédonie
n'ont jamais
en termes culturels
est ce que moi je dois me changer
pour que vous me comprenez ou est ce que
le fait de ne pas changer vous comprenez
ça pour une marque de respect ou pas on
n'avait pas besoin de changer
on reste en parlait d' c'est bon en
chine on dit
comment dire les choses de ce monde
se développe sans rivalité comme les
quatre saisons s'alternent sans
contradiction
on peut aller de l'avant en parallèle
sans se croiser c'est beau mais bon bien
sûr on peut faire des échanges
sans se déranger sans se déranger comme
les chinois utilisent les paquet pour
manger chez nous il est le couteau et la
fourchette renault ne nous ont appris
quelque chose de beaucoup plus efficace
les baguettes c'est plus facile tous les
jours ça fait moins de vaisselle
ça fait moins de vaisselle c'est plus
efficace et puis c'est très bien
d'ailleurs pour cuisiner ça évite de se
brûler les doigts c'est absolument
magnifique
revenons revenons à des sujets un peu
plus arides
quand dans un rapport français qui ont
parti fait par notre armée
ils ont l'air d'être très inquiet
sur votre organisation pour maîtriser
votre communication à l'extérieur avec
cette fameuse légende de lou gehrig
comment vous vous le prenez est-ce que
lou guerrier c'est péjoratif
est-ce que c'est pas péjoratif
est-ce que c'est respecter en chine le
fait d'être un guerrier ou pas est-ce
qu'il ya des mouvements dissonant qui
disent quand même le guerrier c'était un
peu trop agressif on va se faire
beaucoup d'ennemis
alors effectivement
il existe
comment dire un mouvement sinon une
guerre médiatique aux biens
informationnels
de la part
de certains pays occidentaux
contre la chine oui comme ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure on en reste au reste
du jouant défensif on ne fait que
riposter
répondre et en ce qui concerne le
guerrier en effet c'est le nom d'un film
chinois espoirs
chinois google 1 mondy chinois yu woo-ik
cas-là callaway
cela cela démontre le courage de combat
pour défendre l'activité les intérêts de
la patrie et défendre la sécurité du
peuple donc loup guerrier dans ce film
là c'est un mot
pas péjoratif remets le contraire c'est
méjean mais l'aura mélioratif
hommage au major hâtives même c'est pas
péjoratif
c'est positif
mais dans la boue ce
que la presse occidentale
il essaie de transformer l'accord la
connotation de ce mot là pour qui le
devenir un mot péjoratif
alors c'est leur chose
je m'en fous
ou es ce que vous avez parlé à part où
est ce que vous avez appris à parler
français en chine
totalement en chine j'ai jamais fait
d'études à l'étranger
en afrique qu'un an et j'ai fait
beaucoup de voyages en afrique
francophone ou anglophone et francophone
j'ai fait était poste dans en afrique
francophone en guinée conakry au sénégal
parce que j'ai toujours ouais alors j'ai
fait aussi des voyages de mission dans
d'autres pays africains anglophones
lusophones
je peux je peux me prix dont en europe
que je suis un monsieur africain
je vois la visité plus de quarantaine de
pays africains
au lof où je ne jouais pas bien parler
et pu vous parler plus je connais ce
sont des langues parlées soyez
je parle français c'est parce que le
français sol et la langue utilisée
officielle de ces pays là
alors ma question c'est est pourquoi
avoir choisi trois mots de la langue
française pour décrire un chercheur et
un journaliste ya une folle d'où est-ce
que ça sort alors autant août en août
entre all idéologique
c'est bah c'est pas pour décrire les
journalistes heures ou bien les
chercheurs c'est pour décrire les gens
qui stigmatise la chine ou es ce que
vous avez trouvé ces boues parce que yen
folle
c6
ça sort d'où vont compenser ou de ce mot
là yen yen folle alors moi moi j'aime
être ami avec les isles est précis ou
bien pas précis est-ce que vous allez
écrire à cela vous avez vu le film
français qui s'appelle bernie noël oh
vous avez pas vu bernie noël non il faut
voir ce film
bernie noël
donc y'a une folle la hyène c'est celle
qui rigole tout le temps c'est ça
qui fait le bruit de rigoler tout le
temps c'est ça et folle parce que
c'est une expression qu'on connaît qu'on
connaissait pas trop idéologique on peut
comprendre idéologie ouais c'était quoi
le troisième que vous avez utilisé
ils frappent petit alors ça c'est pas
mal ou est ce que vous avez trouvé ça
dans les journaux dans les journaux et
dans quel jour nous oui dans les
journaux français petite frappe les les
chronos mais jamais petites frappes dont
les grands journaux oui il y en a je lis
je lis tous les jours la presse
française ouais un pouce et on utilise
ça sinon je ne connais pas bon alors
nous on s'est dit enfin un diplomate on
n'est pas d'accord avec lui parce que
s'exprimer comme ça sur les réseaux en
tant qu ambassadeur d'un peuple de 1400
milliards de 1 milliard 400 millions
c'est quand même ça choque
c'est vous comprenez ou pas que c'est
toujours aux vases et de sa charte chez
vous ça choque peut-être pas mais chez
nous ça choque aux
anneaux mais franchement les gens
sachant qu'en terme de mes gants quand
il attaque la chine iso il utilise des
mots vous ne pensez pas que ça sorte
si je peux couple est pourquoi ils
peuvent choquer ils ne peuvent pas être
choqué il faut parler comment de la
chine pour éviter de prendre un vol dans
la tête aucun décès en chine il est à
mort sans gros comme on dit fong fong
fong
alors quand je traduit en français
je change le mot quand on sait le chien
je connais le chien ouais je connais que
le chien est l'ami
des occidentaux n'est ce pas c'est
pourquoi on a changé le mot
le moule ou chinois ça veut dire quoi
fong au fond qu ça veut dire chien chien
fou hein
mais il fallait utiliser chien fou et
pourquoi parce que en français nous tend
entend l'utiliser dès lisez aussi chien
fou cheval fou à rossi a baissé pour
décrire quelqu'un qui n'est pas très
bon corner ca je ne suis pas français
donc peut-être je ne peux pas manipuler
le français comme les français et
excusez moi si ça vous chante
est-ce que alors ça peut choquer comme
ça peut ça peut plaire
ça a l'air de plaire en chine le fait
que les diplomates
mettre l'accélérateur sur le fait
maintenant ça suffit on prend ce qui
nous est ce qui nous appartient et on
occupe le siège dans la géopolitique
mondiale d'une façon sereine mais on ne
se laisse pas faire c'est ça votre
approche
il y a plusieurs approches pour les
diplomates donc il ya de la loi il y à
lacoste ou plus à rennes ille et à la
proche des ovaires
vous pourriez qualifier nos propres
diplomates
est-ce qu'ils ont un langage
vernaculaire hypocrite est aussi
pertinent qu'un filet d'eau tiède
ou est-ce qu'ils ont un langage
diplomatique qui convenu et qui est
nécessaire je pense que la langue
diplomatique doit être
comment dire sur la base
de
l'objectivité la véracité
la
commande irrationalité
et bien sûr aussi nécessaire il faut
avoir la compétitivité aux mathes elite
et oui ça prend quelle forme quand on
est ambassadeur ça prend la forme de on
répond à un journaliste ou un chercheur
qui critique et on l'envoie dans ses
cages avec une insulte du janvier mme
fall s'est fait la forme ne s'est jamais
provoquer mais jamais n'hésitez jamais
hésité de se défendre de riposter jamais
provoquer mais jamais hésité à
riposter est-ce que vous pouvez entendre
leurs arguments
quand par exemple nous on entend on lit
dans notre presse on voit des
documentaires on a aussi des gens chez
vous
quand on entend voilà les ouigours ils
sont stérilisés ils sont envoyés dans
des camps d'internement à hauteur de
millions personnes ils sont harcelés
sont fliqués toute la journée sont
fliqués avec le numérique leurs
téléphones portables ils sont écoutés
ils sont notés
çà ressemble un petit peu
quand même est ce que quand je vous
présente ses arguments de cette façon là
vous vous sentez à agacer attaquer c'est
quoi votre réalité sur le sujet des
ouigours vous parlez du cygne jambes
oui la réalité c'est ce que présente la
l'ambassade de chine
peut-être pas ce que moi je connais mes
ambassades française et des fois il
raconte des trucs ils maîtrisent pas
leur sujet
j'ai déjà pas bien saisir selon o des
fois nous nos ambassades parlent ils
maîtrisent pas très bien le sujet est ce
que vous vous maîtrisez sujet là quand
moi j'aimais chercheurs français ils ont
été tués sur quand même les chinois ils
sont très très très très très très très
difficile avec les ouigours
c'est quand même
c'est quand même asséné un sacré
argument vous stérilisés à 12 euros
on croyait ça je ne crois pas pour
l'instant ouais mais je pense que je
vais me déplacer sur place chez vous est
ce que j'aurai un visa oui après la
bande d'amis après un premier set ça on
verra est ce que vous faites de la
rétention de visas pour les chercheurs
les journalistes est-ce que moi si je
vous appelle je vous dis voilà au je
voudrais partir en chine et je veux une
liberté absolument totale et je suis en
capacité
de voir si vous essayez de me tracer
chez vous
est ce que vous allez me laisser aux
allées en chine comme un touriste dans
un coma twist je suis en train de dire
je veux prendre leurs journalistes un
visa professionnels ouais foule pouvoir
il y à des règlements pour les
professionnels quel type chine mais je
ne connais pas exactement parce que je
ne suis pas danseuse dans ce domaine
mais il y à des règlements chaque pays à
aso règlements propres oui il faut
respecter les règlements locaux
dans le pays que vous visitez n'est ce
pas
mais si vous voulez visiter
lashes ya bien je veux enquêter je veux
discuter avec les gens sans avoir trois
cargaisons bien rock été enquêtés
enquêter à je veux en fait aline pour
weiss a dépassé aussi vous voulez
enquêter peut-être les autorités
compétentes du gouvernement chinois peut
traiter d'une façon
différente
pourquoi je ne sais pas si ce sont des
règlements et règlements chinois par
exemple j'ai joué n'importe quel pays je
vivrai il y a le respect le respect du
pays hôte n'est ce pas je vous pose la
question différente je me suis mal
exprimé excusez moi
si moi je veux me déplacer avec mon
équipe pour aller vérifier les ouigours
et je veux je veux pas faire le tour
pour les touristes
nous on voyait jamais en touriste on
voyage on va dormir chez les gens on va
dormir des fois dans la rue on va
écouter les gens ce qui se passe on est
très doué pour faire ça si moi je veux
faire ça chez vous est ce que c'est
possible ou pas
si on dit que vous allez faire des
enquêtes alors
à vrai dire c'est pas c'est pas honnête
parce que la chine n'a pas commis de
faute pourquoi on doit être enquêter
alors investi que je vais je vais
m'exprimer différemment
oui - j'entends dans ma presse
des choses je fais confiance en partie à
la presse
mais je reçois aujourd'hui ça c'est
notre avantage d'une communauté je
reçois aujourd'hui l'ambassadeur de gym
et au bois y aller en tant que touristes
et même
partout pourquoi vous devez parce que
j'ai des copains rendre prendre le
quartz nom de
enquête
par effet enquêté c'est que ça signifie
que quelqu'un a commis des erreurs même
des crimes il faut enquêter c'est signé
la chine n'a là n'a rien commis pourquoi
vous vous inquiétez je parle d'une
enquête pour voir de mes propres yeux il
ya les en tant que touriste on pouvait
voir aussi allé un peu partout voir tous
dans le rapport en question il est
marqué noir sur blanc que vous faites de
la rétention de visas pour influencer la
recherche sur la chine et influencer la
perception de la chine est ce que c'est
vrai c'est pas vrai l'athée livraison de
visa relève de la souveraineté d'un état
oui oui les américains
refusent des visas a beaucoup de chinois
est ce que on les accusait
maintenant tout ça sans moi l'ambassade
américaine je me reposais qui
sortira mérite à roger izao général je
vais leur dire voilà pourquoi vous
refuser des visas ou chinois mais je
sais déjà ce qu'ils vont me répondre
salah s'ils vont me dire ils vont me
dire on a de fortes suspicions pour que
cette personne la face du renseignement
chez nous les américains laisse pas
attendre de faire ça alors c'est c'est
le réseau donc donc c'est la musique
saison de visa relève du coup de la
souveraineté des états unis on ne peut
pas on peut se plaindre on peut se
plaindre 0 on a rien à faire n'est ce
pas
quand il s'agit de la chine sur la même
chose là des livraisons de visa relève
de notre souveraineté de notre pays et
aussi pour la fois où ça aussi vous
pouvez refuser le visa à n'importe qui
n'est ce pas
revenons en au sujet
quand
on parle de crédit social en chine votre
corps sait combien je n'ai pas de coach
veut pas côtes n'ont eu comme ça sinon
on à onna la carte d'identité pour
chaque citoyen chinois une carte comme
en france vous avez aussi la carte
d'identité
le crédit social c'est ce qu'on apprend
auprès des pays occidentaux
mais intéressant ça ouais tout d'abord
ce sont les états unis qui appliquent ce
système mais quand exemple la carte
bancaire lesparre vous avez un crédit
social l'a6 où on ne rembourse pas
l'argent à temps alors
vous devez être
votre crédit sera sera comment dire un
peu hâlé entier un peu été détruits
mais un mot aux états unis je connais
très très bien venir
si j'ai plus d'argent sur mon compte en
banque je comprends votre parallèle avec
le crédit social pomme en parallèle avec
l'argent je comprends le fichage sur une
banque parce que vous avez des impayés
ainsi de suite
en chine d'après ce que j'ai pu voir
votre crédit social c'est un peu au bon
vouloir au site du parti c'est à dire
imaginez-vous chinois mon prénom chinois
ce serait quoi d'ailleurs bon moi moi
votre prêt dans ce film-là sa joie je
vous pose la question c'est quoi mon
prénom chinois votre prénom chinois or
veut dire oui mon nom en arabe c'est à
ben salem c'est à dire l'homme de paix
comme envoûtera 18,5 préjudice en chine
où tu après la prononciation l'homme de
paix revenons la prononciation abou
salam absolument oui
bon passons cette boutade si moi je vais
là-bas et que je suis pas trop d'accord
avec le parti
est ce que ma note elle va être baissé
je ne pense pas ça je ne pense pas ça
qui nous crise sociale en chine c'est
c'est effectivement comme le cri le
critique
sociale car les pays occidentaux ça veut
dire par exemple si vous ne remplissez
pas l'argent de la banque alors votre
crédit abbès baisse oui la prochaine
fois quand vous voulez prêter de
l'argent pour acheter une maison la
banque ne vous prête pas ne vous en
prenez pas si par contre est-ce que je
vais t'en empêcher le voyage est de
prendre le train de prendre le view
simoneau télé par benoît c'est pour tes
gars
extrêmement grave
d'après ce que je sais dans les
reportages par exemple il y a des gens
qui a qui a droit
beaucoup d'argent à
un autre à une autre personne alors
cette personne là le traduit dans la
dans la cour
la cour à faire un verdict pour qu'il
rembourse ses d'argent mais ils refusent
à l'otan ce cas là il y à des mesures et
punisse ouais une mesure de punition par
exemple par exemple vous avez lorsque
j'ai pas d'argent pour rembourser je
suis pauvre alors si vous êtes pauvre où
on fait se découvrent des consommations
encore de luxe donc c'est contradictoire
c'est vous c'est généralement c'est ce
cas là ouais le fait que le fait
d'afficher leur tête dans les rues ou
allant à l'entrée des immeubles de
mettre les portraits des des mauvais
citoyens
culturellement danser ça ne s'est pas
affiché 1,6 et montréjeau mauvais
citoyen passe ici ses marques et ses
maquettes matte et vous qui en chinois
non je n'ai jamais vu à au moins
personnellement j'ai jamais vu peut-être
je suis vous est incertain j'ai jamais
vu ce genre de cas quoi on est affichée
dans sur et dans un immeuble telle ou
telle personne existe un si je vous dise
existe ça existe ah ok mais j'ai jamais
vu jamais combien ça gagne l'ambassadeur
ont tous là un nouveau cédant chinois en
france
oui mais bien sur
notre salaire a été compté par en lien
dmi be
mais puisqu'on travaille à l'étranger
pour la facilité de vie aux touches des
monnaies locaux locale combien
c'était la vie privée a annoncé par du
bruit si les en poudre vos concitoyens
moi si j'ai un ambassadeur français qui
veut pas me donner ce concert vous
inquiétez pas je vais pas lâcher parce
que je paye des impôts mais un
fonctionnaire public en chimie peut pas
dire son salaire
non
ici on ne paie pas les impôts le vous
pouvez pas dire votre salaire
je ne dis pas d'accord
une petite fourchette ses 10000 15000
non non je sais moi
j'aurais essayé oui c'est ma vie privée
est ce que la vie privée en chine
on peut on peut en avoir
avec toutes ces caméras la
reconnaissance faciale le traçage de
téléphone pour sa raison des techniques
modernes pour bien
aménager mais ménagé la société vous
entendez par aménager la société bien
on veut dire organisé bien organisée oui
on dit il y à des caméras mais ce sont
des caméras dans l'espace public n'est
ce pas qu'ils vont pouvoir nous t'aimons
crédit social
non c'est pas
c'est pas pour
superviser les mets et élégant si je
traverse pas dans les clous connaissez
du cloud les passages piétons si je
traverse pas dans les clous est-ce que
je vais avoir une mauvaise note non les
crocs l'écossais quoi des passages
piétons passage là on doit traverser la
route pour les piétons non non non il
n'y a pas d'eau non ça ne sent ça
n'impacte pas
les soi-disant crédit social non du tout
tuto nasa n'a rien à voir
c'était vraiment
bizarre à ceux de vous raconter c'est
pour ça que je vous ai fait venir oui
c'est vous voyez de vos propres yeux ou
bien où roga vous entendez dd oui
tiens kwakwa oui vire
t ouï dire
qu'ils n'ont pas de
fondement je vais vous lire un extrait
qui m'a
interpellé dans le rapport et je vais
vous poser une question oui
après vous avoir lu ce petit extrait
l'air ce trade ce rapport page 29
les opérations dont le domaine cognitif
quoi cognitif cognitif cognitif c'est
quoi la sensation
cognitif et la lutte dans le domaine
cognitif
est l'un des concepts développés ces
dernières années par l'apn le but d
autres de ses opérations excusez-moi
j'ai texte qui a sauté je reprends tout
de suite
le but de ces opérations est de
constituer un pouvoir de contrôle du
cerveau c'est-à-dire une capacité
d'utiliser la guerre psychologique pour
façonner mêmes contrôles et les
capacités cognitives de l'ennemi et de
la prise de décision
ces concepts opérations dans le domaine
cognitif et pouvoir de contrôle des
cerveaux sont apparus en 2012 et le
second est hétéro théorisé dans un livre
paru en janvier 2014
dont l'un de ses co auteur le professeur
zheng
liu fang
doyen de l'école de l'ue de l'humanité
des sciences sociales de l'université
nationale des technologies de défense
zen définit le pouvoir de contrôle du
cerveau comme le fait d'utiliser des
informations spirituel psychologique
véhiculée par les médias de propagande
la langue nationale les produits
culturels comme une arme pour infiltrer
influencé
et même dirigé la connaissance l'émotion
et la conscience du public et des élites
de la nation
le but ultime est de manipuler les
valeurs l'esprit l'ethos nationale les
idéologies la tradition culturelle les
croyances historique c'est un pays pour
les inciter à abandonner leur
compréhension théorique leur système
social et leur voie de développement est
d'atteindre les objectifs stratégiques
sans victoire les travaux dans ce
domaine intimement liée aux avancées en
matière d'intelligence artificielle
je pense que l'auteur de ce rapport à à
lui trop de roman des romands fictif
scientifique oui mais je pense que si il
existe dans la réalité
ce sont
comment dire
essentiellement les américains qui ont
cette capacité de quelle manière
quelle manière
tout à l'heure aux manières de leur
manière la chine fera pas cette
technologie n'a pas cette capacité je
pense que c'est c'est vraiment
fantasque 1
fictif c'est fictif
très les romans fictif scientifique
déclarations ces déclarations d'un
chinois que vous connaissez c'est lui
qui a créé le crédit social chez vous
vraiment il connaît bien il connaît
mieux que moi oui le rapport met
généralement
jeudi
certains certains
chercheurs dans le monde occidental
quand il écrit des rapports de recherche
sur la chine c'est souvent à leur propre
image
c'est une projection
psychologique ont bien une pensée miroir
ça veut dire tout ce nom ce dont ils
accusent la chine c'est souvent ce
qu'ils ont fait auparavant
oui ils n'ont pas attendre d imagination
d exemple pour ça j'ai pas besoin de
données vous pouvez voir tous les
mensonges qu'il raconte c'est
certainement c'est certainement pas par
exemple génocide et oui au près il
accuse un field de génocide aussi tiens
mais
effectivement
la génocide a eu lieu en amérique en
europe sepa en chine jamais ça il ya
longtemps ça il ya longtemps
même si c'est il ya longtemps mais il
s'inspire de l'histoire
pour accuser la chine
quand quand on touche à l'âme de la
chine c'est ce qui réveille les loups
gris
quoi quand on touche à l'âme de la chine
tous lam lam à de soul
quand on touche à l'âme de la chine
c'est ce qui réveille les loups guerrier
je pense que c'est cette différence
n'est pas le clou guerrier qui
qui est
en jeu
pourquoi tout cela l'âme cela cela
rappelle le réveil et le look here in
essai s'est passé pas exact
autre touche à l'âme de la france oh
ça réveille nous des nues
ok c'est différent c'est c'est la
différence de culture la culture
chinoise reste toujours très modéré we
no no
bossu veau ou bien nous
préconisons la doctrine du juste milieu
ça veut dire on ne va jamais à
l'extrémité quand on traite les choses
on reste toujours au milieu
modéré si moudéry
d'appeler les journalistes pour les
menacer
on n'est jamais au ne menace jamais
personne
est-ce que c'est modiri d'appui un
journaliste
et lui parlait un peu fermement
mais la riposte à de différentes
manières n'est ce pas c'est ce que je
dis on ne provoque que jamais mais on a
le droit de répondre
écrit ou parlementaires français pour
dire que vous étiez pas content qu'il
ait qu'ils aillent se déplacer à taïwan
est ce que vous avez et des lettres bien
sûr j'ai eu outre les très grands pas
rêver du joli papier d'ailleurs qu'en
pensez vous
c'est pas moi c'est pas vous de poser
des questions ici
d'accord je suis pas là pour penser moi
je suis là pour poser des questions oui
à ce que ça se fait un diplomate
qui écrit ou parlementaire d'un pays
c'est ce que ça se fait c'est normal
je peux écrire à n'importe qui n'est ce
pas
été convoqué par le parent ne ministre
le drion vous voyez un petit peu le
drian
il a dit quoi ils faisaient tirer
l'oreille vous a parlé d'une façon très
diplomatique que celle à faire entre un
mois et le ministère
ministère c'est nous parce que nous on
paye le ministère des affaires
étrangères donc c'est nous le ministère
affirme que vous avez vous adressé au
ministère va servir comme ça moi c'est à
eux de s'adresser à nous c'est nos
employés
n'a voté vais vous devez vous adresser à
vos employés oui bon en fait on on
s'adresse plus à eux parce qu'ils
veulent plus travailler correctement
donc on prend les rênes en main et on
invite l'ambassade chinoise donc vous
voulez pas dire ce qui vous a dit
il vous a dit loup quand même tu
déconnes il vous a dit monsieur je me
suis moi c'est pas du tout pourquoi je
dois vous dire ça parce que c'est
intéressant ça intéresse
vous avez déjà vu étant le reportage ce
n'est ce pas non mais pourquoi leurs
portes de l'est la presse ne reporte pas
la
presse n'a pas dit on fait ce que ce
dont vous avez échangé ceux ci ils ne
disent pas les autres choses ça veut
dire ce ne sont pas les choses à dire ça
c'est le problème de la presse ont
normalement on doit pouvoir tout dire
oui vous êtes d'accord avec moi oui donc
pourquoi vous les patoisants tout dire
tout tout dire ce que je peux dire n'est
ce pas est ce qui vous empêche de de
parler vous avez vous avez donné votre
parole
tout dire ça veut pas dire que toutes
sortes chose c'est tout ce que je peux
dire mais je n'ai pas je n'ai pas besoin
de créer des problèmes tu espères train
de couvrir mon propre ministre vous êtes
en train de protéger mon ministre
je ne savais pas protégé voir ici là-bas
besoins des classes
vous savez il y a dans ce monde
toujours des limites n'est ce pas même
pour la liberté d'expression la liberté
de presse
il ya des limites il y à respecter il
doit respecter des des lois les pâtes et
des coutumes des
correct d'été politiquement correct
n'est ce pas est ce que l'amour a des
limites ou est ce que l'amour à des
lignes l'amour au est ce que l'amour à
l'élite d'après vous l'amour un abat est
ce qu'il y a des limites est ce qu'il ya
des mythes à l'amour à la mort oui j'ai
des limites à l'amour je pense que c'est
difficile à dire ah parce que
cela dépend mais l'amour c'est pas la
politique
des spas bonnes réponses
moi j'ai une autre question comment ça
se fait qu'il ya beaucoup de petites
chinoises est en général très très belle
qui viennent traîner à côté nos base de
sous marins
et qui viennent traîner à côté de nous
sommes de nous sous mariniers
comment ça se fait c'est quoi voulez
comment ça se fait qu'il ya des petites
chinoises les types nom des petites les
petites chinoises oui qui viennent oui
se marier avec nous sous marinier france
as se marier sous marinier ils se
mariaient son mari et se massent aux
mariés oui comment ça se fait et comment
ça se fait que nous services de
renseignement 10 attention les chinoises
elles font peut-être du renseignement
chez nous au je ne connais pas on ne
fait pas déranger les marchés où y'a pas
d'hirondelles non vous faites pas de
renseignements chez nous non non c'est
pas vrai vous avez vous fait pas du tout
renseignement chez nous renseignements
renseignements pour quoi conférence est
les moins chers au poids acte
acquisition de connaissances
technologiques acquisition de réseau
lecture de résout mapping de la
connaissance
scientifique aux biens technologiques et
humaines le renseignement humain ouais
c'est pour pour faire prendre la
connaissance scientifique ou bien
technologie que c'est un échange
normales entre les différents pays n'est
ce pas nous avons des étudiants des
jeunes étudiants chinois he chez vous
vous avez aussi des étudiants chez nous
c'était c'est un échange humaine et soit
dans votre pays vous dites avoue femmes
méfiez vous des hommes occident tout
beau parleur
vous avez dit ça
non non non vous n'avez pas dissuadé
vous femme de se marier avec nous non
jamais jamais jamais oui peut-être il y
a des dizaines d'années il existait ce
phénomène là parce que la chine n'était
pas encore ouverte les chinois auront un
peu avait un peu peur des étrangers ils
ne connaissent pas bien les pays
étrangers mais mecs là pas du tout âge
pensent et tous tes livres tous les tons
les chinoises aux livres à se marier
avec les étrangers vous faites vous
faites vous m'avez dit que vous ne
faisiez pas de renseignements chez nous
est-ce que vous maintenez cette
déclaration ouais bien sûr donc il n'ya
pas de cyber espionnage si les cyber
espionnage y'a pas il n'ya pas des
étudiants chinois dans étudiants chinois
qui se font reconduire leur dire non non
pas d'un passé pas du tout pas du tout
alors je connais cyber espionnage c'est
ce dont les occidentaux à guise souvent
la chine mais toujours comme ceux de
jeudi tout ce dos ils accusent la chine
des cyber attaques chinoises sont sous
kg fait et ils sont en train de faire
vous comprenez c'est encore votre voûte
par exemple si verva espionnage c'est
par les chinois qui le font ce sont les
occidentaux qui le font
les américains
les chinois ils sont très forts pour
copier améliorée vous êtes d'accord avec
moi on n'a pas besoin de copier comme
andy coupions chinois vous savez le
diplomate chinois chang chia est ce que
ça veut vraiment dire coupures
vous savez la chine maintenant à la
grande capacité d'innovation
pendant plusieurs années consécutives
le nombre de dépôts
de brevets
chinois
sont les premiers c'est normal
oui mais mais pourquoi on copie encore
on n'a pas on n'a pas besoin de copier
plus besoin c'est pas plus besoin
auparavant quand au début de l'ouverture
de la chine laisse pas la chine était
arriérés sur le plan scientifique
technologique
on apprend auprès des occidentaux
ont fait des échanges c'est normal c'est
apprendre la auprès de l'autre c'est pas
copier c'est pas copier c'est pas copier
chez nous messi s'est confiée au cabinet
aussi la chine n'est ce pas les occitans
les occidentaux aussi vous tient même
chose vous coupent ue
on voulait donner me donner une preuve
une épreuve pour pour pour dire que la
chine à copier quelque chose auprès des
accidents quels domaines au beau et dans
l'épreuve ben en exemple quand vous
allez me dire qu les lois de
l'aérodynamique sont les mêmes pour tous
les avions mais moi quand je regarde
vous avions on y ressemble vachement
vous avions des autres
les avions au sort se ressemblent tous
quand je reviens comme les voitures ils
ont tour à quatre roues
sicile une voiture n'a seulement trois
roues deux roues c'est pas une voiture
c'est un tuk-tuk ses seins ou en tout
cas
c'est pas copier c'est celle à metz si
vous voulez fabriqué en avion vous devez
avoir la forme d'avion alors je vais
vous pouvez
voir à la forme d'une voiture c'est vrai
que des fois on regarde vos voitures
elles ont des formes bizarres c'est un
peu comme au plus ils ont des formes
bizarres et peut-être demain
y'a quoi en avion en forme voiture
revenons revenu à la sibérie aussi bien
espionnage
pourquoi les pays occidentaux alors si
la chine ne fait pas de renseignement et
si la chine ne copie pas si la chine ne
fait pas de cyberattaques pourquoi on
retrouve des traces
de groupe en chine faisant des
cyberattaques chez nous des traces
effectivement la chine et le victime de
cyber attaques de cyberespionnage
pays occidentaux mais surtout des
américains
louis est pourquoi les les pays
occidentaux désignent la chine comme une
menace en termes de cyberattaques avec
ses légions pirates gésiers c'est ce ce
qu'ils ont fait ce don et accusent la
chine et ce qu'ils ont fait
il faut être deux pour faire une guerre
non on il faut être deux pour faire une
guerre
il fait il faut être deux pour danser le
tango n'est-ce pas vous danser le tango
non mais moi non plus
il faut être deux pour faire une guerre
est ce que vous pensez vous qu'il y
avait plus de 5000 ans d'histoire
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est pas
immature
avec l'antériorité de vos racines
de pratiquer cet effet miroir en disant
ils ont commencé on va leur montrer
qu'on peut faire mieux avec leur propre
méthode est ce que vous pensez que ce
n'est pas prendre la direction de la
guerre
lâcher d'un ne veut pas la guerre
oui veut pas la guerre ok
moi mon voisin gérard voisin
je vais vous raconter une fausse
histoire parce que mon voisin est très
gentil
mon voisin m'ennuie
mon voisin m'ennuie parce qu'on n'arrive
pas à se comprendre
et mon voisin il m'ennuie tellement et
on se comprend tellement pas que je vais
lui déclarer la guerre
on les dit qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire qu' un problème d'incompréhension
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour qu'on se
comprenne mieux vous les chinois et nous
les européens occidentaux si vous voyez
la chine préconise est toujours le
dialogue et la consultation habituelle
la concordance ouais cordes la concorde
oui
oui dans notre langue la grande concorde
l'harmonie n'est ce pas oh on veut
toujours
résoudre les problèmes les divergences
ce même les dykes tish par voie de
dialogue par voie de négociations mais
pas par la force c'est notre philosophie
c'est notre philosophie mais bien sûr si
quelqu'un décroche la guerre quand vous
l'avez dit on est obligé de relever le
défi
le budget défense a explosé depuis les
dix dernières années c'est nécessaire la
chine est un grand pays
nous avons une superficie de 2 9 me diot
1 600 mille kilomètres carrés nous avons
une population de 1,4 milliard nous
devons avoir la capacité les moyens de
nous défendre
n'est ce pas et le budget militaire de
la chine et beaucoup moi beaucoup
inférieur à celui des américains
ça ça c'est un argument qui tient plus
la route 1 ça c'est un argument qui
tient plus la route pourquoi parce que
moi pour 10 balanchine je peux me faire
25 caleçon que aux états unis pour dubaï
j'ai même pas la moitié d'une jambe donc
si je dois construire de l'armement en
chine ouais avec la le faible coût de la
main d'oeuvre
votre budget militaire en dollars c'est
pratiquement le même que celui des etats
unis
vous êtes faut encore oui c'est toujours
je me trouvais toujours été déformés oui
le temps
dans les médias mais violente en des
institutions de recherche
des pays occidentaux et alizée de ashes
exagère toujours la menace elle le coup
quel est le salaire moyen en chine
quel est le cerveau les traits je veux
savoir combien beaucoup beaucoup moins
retrait inférieur le salaire moyen en
chef je ne n'ai pas le chiffre du jour
donne je donne
le pib par tête de la chine public qui
veut pas dire grand-chose aimerait bien
suivre alors le salaire moyen
il ya différentes milieu différentes
couches sociales n'est ce pas cet hiver
en douane les salaires le salaire moyen
des grands patrons c'est énorme
pas de classe moyenne en chine où il y
en a il y en a près le classe moyenne au
nombre de 400 millions n'est ce pas mais
ça ne me dit rien non plus sur ans quand
il s'agit du budget militaire vous
connaissez le budget militaire des états
unis dépasse
les 9 pays qui les suit
de total tt budget militaire des neuf
pays qui le suit
je sais pas si on peut comparer les
choux et les courgettes mais en termes
de coûts de production je sais que si je
dois faire mon porte avions gérer le fer
en chine
parce que ça va me coûter moins cher que
si je le faisais aux états unis vous
êtes d'accord avec moi ça voulait dire
le court le coût de fabrication d
exactement mais on ne peut pas dire
comme ça on ne peut bâtir comme ça oui
mais les chinois gagnent encore un peu
pour moi n'est ce pas
est ce que le guen est sous-évalué a dit
saint lô s'est passé votre sous-évalué a
le taux le taux
le taux des u11
évolue
sur le marché ouais maintenant personne
n'accuse pas la chine de sous estimés
sous-évalués
notre monnaie non
même les états unis no
est ce que la chine
est un géant aux pieds d'argile ou
est-ce que la chine était une bombe à
retardement socialement parlant je
m'explique on
sait
qui dit grand pays dits grande question
des d'accord
vous êtes sorti de là
de l'ultra pauvreté avec le miracle
chinois c'est ça en quarante ans vous
êtes sortis du sol avec de la terre à
des building encore plus moderne que la
défense appareils qui en seulement
quarante ans le pacte tacite vous
m'arrêtez je parle sous votre contrôle
le pacte tacite entre le parti
communiste le parti état et la
population c'est du moment où je vous
fais mieux vivre vous êtes derrière nous
on est d'accord
il faut pas
dire la chose de cette manière alors
reformuler à reformuler leur courage les
émois dire
pour tous les pays les gouvernements ont
la vocation d'améliorer le niveau de vie
de la population le bien-être de la
population s'il ne peut pas réussir à
améliorer la vie de la population
ito quitter le pouvoir n'est ce pas mais
chez vous cet hiver entre la chine quand
vous quittez
où on ne pouvait pas rare et améliorer
la vie de la population alors au change
on peut revenir lors de la prochaine
sauf
s'ouvre âge non un ouvrage scrutin vu
que l'élection ouais
pour la chine aussi le parti communiste
chinois
à un engagement initial
c'est
servir le peuple
ces oeuvres et au bonheur du peuple
chinois et au renouveau de la nation
chinoise
c'est notre engagement initial on reste
fidèle à ses engagements
donc pendant des dizaines d'années des
dernières dizaines d'années
cette année c'est le centenaire de la
création du parti communiste chinois
pendant les 100 ans
le parti communiste chinois l'a jamais
vous plier son engagement initial il a
fait toutes ses photos ses efforts pour
satisfaire au peuple chinois pour
réaliser le renouveau de la nation
chinoise pour améliorer la vie de la
tuque peuple chinois prix quels
sacrifices aux prix leur propre
sacrifices vous avez pendant les
périodes de la révolution combien de
membres du parti communiste chinois ont
sacrifié leur vie
des dizaines de millions
oui
et après la fondation de la république
populaire de chine s'est toujours le
parti
qui n'a qui ne ménage aucun effort
pour
redresser le pays oui vous évaluez vous
capacité à fournir
sur une fonction exponentielle
le le bien du peuple je m'explique
à l'heure actuelle la chine et us sur
une croissance exponentielle on est
d'accord tant sur sa population sur ses
capacités financières que sur son
armement que sur sa capacité à consommer
en terres arables en agriculture en
boeufs en porc encana en poussins et
j'en passe
nous ici on analyse en fait les
fondamentaux de soutenabilité d'une
société ce qui permet à cette société de
se soutenir
l'engagement vous avez pris auprès de
votre population il est sur une fonction
exponentielle
combien de temps vous pensez que vous
allez être capable de continuer cette
démarche et à quel prix parce que la
population va vous demander un rendement
de ce qu'il ya dans l'assiette dans les
transports dans la qualité de l'air dans
la qualité de la nourriture
est ce que vous pensez que la chine le
parti communiste est assis sur une bombe
à retardement sociale vous avez plus de
1000 émeutes de plus de 1000 personnes
par an en chine
est-ce que vous pensez que le parti
communiste
est à l'aube
d'un conflit dramatique socialement
parlant et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
vous avez déployés le contrôle social
le crédit social la reconnaissance
faciale et j'en passe et des meilleurs
est ce que vous pensez est ce que vous
avez peur
on a peur de ne
pas pouvoir
répondre aux aspirations du peuple
on a peur de ça c'est pourquoi on a
déployé tous nos efforts
pour répondre aux aspirations du peuple
chinois de mener une ennemie une vie
meilleure
quoi
de quoi
le peuple chinois a besoin
le parti communiste chinois le fait par
exemple il y a quelques années
la qualité de l'air
atmosphère intel r et d et détériorer
la population se plaignent énormément
le parti a pris des mesures très
strictes
pour lutter contre on a fermé des
milliers de
sidérurgie au bien des cimenteries qui
est très polio et en seulement quelques
années la qualité de l'air s'est
largement amélioré
vacances et a abordé les questions
d'écologie les consuls les questions
énergétiques
vous voulez rajouter quand même qu'un
mot sur les cyberattaques
ah ouais ouais l'arrière ajoutait un mot
oui je pense que j'ai déjà dit j'ai tout
dit et j'ai rajouté deux mois non non
non donc écologiquement parlant comment
la chine à un milliard quatre
d'habitants
envisage son futur avec le réchauffement
climatique la
chine est un pays responsable
nous apportons notre contribution
à la lutte contre le changement
climatique
du monde
on devait savoir que c'est c'était grâce
aux efforts chinois en 2015 que l'accord
de paris du changement climatique a été
réussi à être
signé
et l'année dernière
le président chinois xi jinping a
déclaré que la chine va atteindre le pic
d'émissions en 2030 et on va réaliser la
neutralité carbone en 2060 donc on se
rend des jugements
ont fait déjà tout doucement
doucement
c'est pas doucement entre la le le pic
d'émissions et la neutralité carbone la
chine
utilise seulement 30 ans et les pays
occidentaux
par exemple les pays européens vont
utiliser 60 ans
ouais bien sûr où vous avez atteint le
pic e émission avant nous je vais pas
certain mais est certain qu'on a atteint
le pic d'émissions vous vous il me
paraît à fécamp ça s'appelle quoi quand
on a atteint le pic la paix que le pic
des messieurs oui ça s'appelle comment
s'appelle une récession
ça va dire on ne commente pas les
ambitions ça veut dire que comme vous
augmentez pas vos émissions et que vous
n'avez pas encore la technologie pour
pouvoir continuer
la croissance exponentielle a dit que
vous avez une récession connaissait le
mot récession quand votre économie elle
tombe
d'autres économies elles tombent depuis
comprenez c'est de faire la transition
sur le cully culminant pour moi le
changement du mode de développement pour
qu'on dit comment ouais bien sûr qu il y
à de nouvelles technologies n'est ce pas
de deux nouveaux modes
de vie et faire des économies des
ressources et
utilisaient des technologies qui permet
de démettre de gaz à effet de serre
beaucoup moi
il y à toujours plus de solutions que
les problèmes par exemple on peut
planter les arbres n'est ce pas
ça un peu on peut contrecarrer un peu la
pollution l'émission de co2 potion près
je vais rentrer plus dans le détail
parce que ça c'est à peu près le sait le
le le c'est un langage qui est très
mainstream
moi je vais vous poser une question
beaucoup plus tôt çi
quand vous avez votre température qui
augmente et que vos taux d'humidité
qui est saturé ça entraîne des
défaillances d'organes si vous n'êtes
pas sous la climatisation ou cachés dans
une grotte
ça veut dire que vous mourrez chez vous
à cause de la chaleur ou
vos taux d'humidité en chine il est
important dans de nombreuses villes et
militer way you did it et la saturation
la saturation de vapeur d'eau dans l'air
donc vous pouvez pu refroidir votre
corps vous avez énormément de personnes
qui vivent dans des régions exposées au
réchauffement climatique et avec un taux
d'humidité
morbide
délétère
est-ce que vous planifiez
de mettre ces populations sous une
climatisation
hypothétique dû à la consommation
énergétique même si une nouvelle
technologie arrive du ciel pour pouvoir
avoir un rendement hyper efficace en
termes énergétiques ou est-ce que vous
planifiez un exode massif de ces régions
qui vont être exposés à des conditions
climatiques invivable
c'est pas comment dire
l'axé cif
en accès de comment dire utilisation des
déserts conditionné n'est ce pas
là je suis en train de vous poser une
question est ce que le gouvernement
chinois est ce que le parti communiste
est pleinement conscient que sa
population est menacée
oui en terme on va dire je peux pas être
plus simple ils sont menacés de mort
s'ils n'ont pas accès à l'énergie facile
energy facile donc qui dit énergie
facile dit climatisation facile clemes à
10h au facv donc et donc résister au
réchauffement climatique vrai est ce que
votre parti votre état est conscient
qu'il ya à peu près 600 millions de
chinois qui vont se retrouver dans des
situations très difficiles
oui oh oh oh réfléchi et pour améliorer
leur leurs conditions de vie ouais pas
de problème
mais s'est progressivement n'est ce pas
il dit à des centaines de millions de
gens qui qui qui a un niveau de vie
encore très très bas mais on essaie de
les élever oui c'est toujours la tâche
du gouvernement chinois
g j'ai une autre question va continuer
sur les réchauffements climatiques et
l'énergie leur sont juste après
c'est une question triple que j'ai noté
parfait comment définiriez
définiriez-vous le mot communiste
aujourd'hui
idem avec le mot capitaliste puis idem
avec les mots démocratie et dictature
ouais alors le premier comme on définit
comme east oui je pense que pour les
chinois
communisme
c'est plutôt une prospérité commune
ouais donc tout le monde
a une vie meilleure c'est le communisme
et d'ailleurs
l'harmonie de la société
c'est notre objectif
et
si on parle
sur le plan international c est la
commune c'est la communauté
d'un test un test un partage et de
l'humanité c'est le sait notre objectif
voulu en fait le système chinois partout
sur terre mais c'est pas là c'est pas le
système chinois c'est pas le sujet du
système chinois c'est notre idéal aux
vastes eaux barousse avait dans
l'antiquité les chinois à cet idéal
c'est la grande concorde depuis
depuis l'antiquité depuis l'antiquité
depuis l'antiquité il y à plus de 2000
ans de 1500 ans
c'est idéal d'avoir un monde de la
grande concorde je pense que c'est c'est
le communisme la grande conque or tu
sais quoi tout le monde a une vie
meilleure est aisé
relativement riche
sansan à craindre la pénurie n'est ce
pas il n'y a pas de guerre
pénurie pénurie pourquoi vous parlez
plus pays phares comme on dit ça cui
phares rebif un cui cui fin puis sa
soeur peggy la pénurie manque n'est ce
pas le dénuement
donc c'est notre idéal mais pourquoi le
parti communiste chinois
veut construire le communisme en chine
c'est pour réaliser cet idéal depuis
l'antiquité ça c'est pas un communisme
de façade parce que quand je vois les
entreprises chinoises ces scellés sont
super capitale histoire et vous parlez
toujours oui le communisme le communisme
signifie aussi les k lite et les
qualités près c'est pourquoi on dit la
prospérité commune c'est égal et qualité
mais et qualité c'est pas égalitarisme
et guitariste c'est une théorie
fondamentalistes
comme le populisme
le populisme ou le cubisme la comédie
c'est parce que vous comprenez
du point de vue idéologique
oui peut-être ou vous pouvez le
comprenez du point de vue dans l'optique
et idéologique
l'ériger
l'antipode de du capitalisme beau c'est
beau oui mais quand même c'est d'un
idéal de l'humanité n'est ce pas ça veut
dire
réaliser une égalité une richesse comme
commune à une harmonie la paix
c'est cette cesse c'est un objectif
c'est pas la paix ou rouleau compresseur
la paix est-ce que c'est pas amener la
paix ou roux louvre suppresseur
mais pourquoi
si on n'est pas d'accord avec cet
objectif on va se faire écraser
non moi la chine n'impose jamais à
personne jamais
jamais impression j'ai l'impression
d'entendre ma grand mère qui me dit je
ne t'imposes pas de manger des assassins
votre camp merde c'est pas la chine seba
la china
la chine fait ce que nous faisons les
spa alors les autres peut constater le
voir si il y a therrien choix alternatif
choix un choix un choix routes
alternatives et oui la route de la chine
est un alternatif vous prêts mais c'est
pas un beau édition
ici on n'impose jamais ouais comme euros
ou acheter des marchandises dans un
magasin où vous pouvez choisir
dans ce monde il n'y a pas un seul
modèle de développement n'est ce pas il
n'y a pas une seule civilisation
il n'y a pas un seul système politique
il n'ya pas un seul une seule idéologie
le monde et de diversité oui
définiriez-vous le définiriez-vous le
capitalisme
le capitalisme
où on connaissez mieux que moi oui parce
que le capitalisme a été propre appliqué
dans les pays occidentaux beaucoup plus
tôt que la chine
c'est c'est ce que les pays occidentaux
présentent aujourd'hui c'est le
capitalisme
n'est ce pas non je suis pas trop
d'accord parce que vu comment on voit
que les marchés boursiers sont
administrés on a l'impression d'être
dans une société communiste les marchés
sont sous perfusion les prix sont
complètement kadri
ça ressemble plus à du communisme que du
capitalisme en ce moment vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec moi le marché c'est un
moyen de développement
c'est un moyen c'est au via un outil un
outil de développement tous les pays
s'il veut se développer
et doit utiliser cet outil c'est le
marché c'est pourquoi la chine pratique
une économie de marché mehal socialiste
et à la chinoise à la chinoise on ne
copie pas auprès des autres même vous
oui c'est ça vous avez raison
parlons un peu finances on va on va
peut-être revenir sur les questions
d'écologie après oui oui bien sûr on a
oublié deux parties de la question donc
vous avez pas fait de définition du
capitalisme est ce que vous pouvez faire
une définition de la du mou démocratie
la chine le parti communiste chinois
depuis sa création poursuit
la démocratie
et
la démocratie qu'on applique en chine 1
chinoise hé oui à la chinoise toujours
apte à adapter à la situation
concrète de la chine à la civilisation
chinoise à la tradition chinoise et
notre démocratie est une démocratie
de
tout le processus ça veut dire au début
le le début jusqu'à la fin le début
c'est
élire un
consulter
c'est pour avant de faire la décision il
faut écouter les différentes opinions
le plus large que possible
pour permettre
la décision d'être la plus correcte et
puis une fois pris la décision on doit
la mettre en oeuvre et temps ce
processus là
on le fait toujours de manière
démocratique
on consulte on on compte sur la
population au consultent les avis de la
population
pour savoir comment
appliquer cette décision et pendant la
mise en oeuvre de cette décision
le gouvernement le parti est supervisé
par
le peuple c'est aussi de manière
démocratique
donc c'est c'est une démocratie de tout
processus
depuis le début jusqu'à la fin
certains chercheurs français
analyse la démocratie elle chinoise
comme une fausse démocratie
ils justifient leur langue leur
perception
jeudi perception
parce qu' il dise voilà le parti
noyautent les élections le parti
communiste à 80 millions de jeunesse du
parti
1 1 un jeune sur cinq de moins de 28 ans
je me trompe peut-être en termes de
chiffres mais beaucoup beaucoup de
jeunes pour influencer les élections
ou pour rapporter ce qu'ils ne
voteraient pas dans l'intérêt du parti
communiste est ce que c'est vrai c'est
fou c'est pas pour apporter les intérêts
du parti communiste c'est pour apporter
les intérêts du peuple
alors en ce qui concerne à la
compréhension
de la connotation de la démocratie cela
dépend de différents pays
la démocratie n'a pas un seul modèle
d'être réalisé
quand de différents pays chaque pays
doit l'adapter à leur propre situation
sinon il ne peut pas s'adapter la
démocratie en afghanistan
est ce que c'est vrai c'est réussi est
ce que c'est un pays où le
vieillissement
eux c'est un pays l'afghanistan bien sûr
ces restes de pays dont l'afghanistan
c'est pas un pays c'est un reste de pays
c'est un pays qui a vécu des décennies
des décennies de guerre la statue
reprendre l'exemple d'autres pays n'est
ce pas la corée du nord
parce que la démocratie est exportable
en corée du nord dans une inde gensac
and india au moins
193 pays souverain n'est ce pas combien
de pays appliquent le système
démocratique
et combien de pays
ont réussi sur le plan de développement
économique
qu'est ce que ça signifie
doit réussi cela signifie que la
démocratie doit s'adapter à la réalité
de différents pays s'il ne s'adaptent
pas il ne peut pas réussir
quel est le but de la démocratie le bus
de la démocratie zemp lui par le peuple
sait c'est le put c'est le développement
du pays c'est l'amélioration de la vie
du peuple c'est le but de la démocratie
sinon à quoi ça sert vous avez une
démocratie mais vous avez la guerre
d'une démocratie oui c'est pas à cause
de la démocratie que l'on développé
c'est après que vous vous êtes développé
que vous avez la démocratie
c'est le résultat la démocratie c'est le
résultat du développement
ou de la consommation énergétique
ou d'un consommation énergétique si si
on n'a pas l'activité pour pouvoir avoir
accès de l'énergie facile on élargit
facile on peut pas avoir démocratie sans
énergie facile ouais pourquoi vous
assistez toujours sur les nages et
facile l'énergie facile excusez moyens
c'est de compréhension l'énergie facile
celle accès facilement à des ressources
énergétiques ah oui je consens à dire il
y à des énergies facile par exemple
pétrole laisse pas le coût d'extraction
est en train d'augmenter
alors quelle est l'énergie facile c'est
fini l'énergie facile cette fine il est
là donc à niveau bon ça finit donc on
doit on doit dépense plus noble des
niveaux d'énergie
c'est très vrai donc on perd du pouvoir
d'achat avec de l'inflation c'est très
très comment vous définiriez-vous
le mot dictature
on n'est pas une dictature
non hameau ah
oui par exemple dans certains pays y
compris des pays dans
l'antiquité depuis lambie de l'antiquité
par exemple
dans les années
catane 1
athènes sparte oui sparte ce peut être
c'est une dictature athènes c'est une
démocratie n'est ce pas un chouchou oui
n'est ce pas et dans l'empiré romain il
ya des périodes dictature il y a des
périodes républicain n'est ce pas alors
de cela
les théoriciens
occidentaux
distingue les différents systèmes
politiques leur l'écho les
dictatures
démocratie etc des rats mais
d'après selon les chinois il ne faut pas
voir l'apparence combien
regard voire seulement la notion n'est
ce pas il faut voir la réalité les sens
toujours
cet exemple que j'osais je vous ai dit
quand le monde entier il y à 193 pays
combien de pays type démocratique
au moins il y à 160 pays démocratiques
à la démocratie mais on penser que tout
pousse et 160 pays
sautez mocratique
dans le temps la notion
de la définition de la théorie
occidental
oui c'est pas une question c'est c'est
une explication
ça veut dire si on réfléchit à ce
problème vous pouvez comprendre
il ne faut pas saisir les problèmes
seulement à partir de l'apparence de la
notion il faut voir les sens
c'est pour ça qu'il faut d'un visa pour
qu'on aille puisse vous après alors la
pandémie après produit est ce qu'un
chinois respecte toujours sa parole
bien sûr
respecte sa parole est ce qu'un chinois
respecte toujours sa parole comme un
russe
la parole comme bruce est ce que vous
savez ce que ça veut dire respecter sa
parole oui oui ça y est c'est quoi
respecter sa valse et si on se dit
quelque chose oui je vais le faire
revient bien à surface et c'est notre
philosophie mais est-ce que vous
respectez votre parole commune russe
pourquoi comme les russes j'ai eu un
petit bout donnent leurs paroles vous sa
vie qui vont la respecter quoi qu'il
arrive latine par contre vous savez pas
contre la chine comme un insecte la
parole comme les chinois
c'est notre tradition c'est notre
civilisation
en chinois on dirait liem bichi chine
qui courent ça veut dire tout ce qu'on
dit sera crédible ouais et puisque on
allie on le fait
passons un autre sujet 1 milliard 400
millions personnes c'est quand même
énorme
comment la chine prévoit de nourrir son
peuple comment la chine prévoit de ne
pas faire peur aux autres puissances
par le comportement prédateur qu'elle
peut avoir sur les matières premières
les terres arables les forêts les océans
c'est compliqué ça non
alors est ce que vous voyez que la
chienne heures
faire comme à dire
arraché aux vielles pillé des terres
arables des forêts ou bien des
ressources à l'étranger comme un
prédateur l'achète
achètent ces prédateurs voici ces
prédateurs 1,6
hssl commerce et non mais c'est pas le
commerce imaginer vous je vous donne je
vous donne une idée
vous allez en afrique acheter des terres
celui qui a toujours vécu dans son
village oui il va plus pouvoir acheter
sa maison gay ok ok jojo's explique vous
m'avez compris le pays qui a acheté le
plat plus de terres en afrique a dit
c'est pas la chine à ce qui c'est les
états unis le royaume uni et les autres
pays occidentaux où vous source les
sources d des institutions de recherche
occidentaux on pouvait
on pouvait recherche sur internet
je fais la fri que depuis plus de vingt
cinq ans je connais bien
tous ceux qui accusent la chine
d'acheter de la terre en afrique
c'est
cfoa s'est vu ajouter un petit peu car
no way si on achète quelques hectares
c'est un problème auquel culte à ré oui
c'est vieux centaine d'hectares ccdh un
problème acheter ou bien loué et la
chine fait ça pour aider les pays
africains à développer l'agriculture
c'est pas comme certains pays
occidentaux
ils ont acheté les terrains à huit super
fan
superficie
équivalant au territoire français
vous connaissez vous connaissez qui
vous pouvez chercher dans l'internet une
communauté de chercheurs ils achètent
ces terres là pas pour résoudre
l'alimentation des pays d'afrique mais
pour
se planter les les plantes comment dire
qui produit bio
carburant
revenons revenons
à la mer de chine
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
cueillait des flottilles de faux
pêcheurs qui viennent harceler les pays
limitrophes de la zone que vous
revendiquez houde et à la barbe des
autres puissances ce sont des vrais
pêcheurs en axel pas on axel jamais
personne
c'est cette zone de mer
c'est
les eaux territoriales
de la chine depuis l'antiquité à ce
tarif là l'afrique et française
c'est pas c'est pas la connerie c'est
pas la colonie a bassiné série circule
au sein des libyens depuis l'antiquité
c'était la chine acquis qui couverts
n'administre cette zone là et il y a
personne qui cote est oui plus récemment
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'était le gouvernement chinois
qui a proclamé ouvertement dans le monde
que notre
halle aux eaux territoriales co
comprennent tel ou tel de plateau
continental du droit international en
termes la convention sur la mer des
nations unies ne renie pas les i3
historique
par exemple vous avez votre maison ou
aux avait eu une autre cour n'est ce pas
la terre de cette course est votre
propriété
après il y à une loi qui dit qu'il faut
pas avoir une ceinture de cours il faut
démolir les ceintures
et les voisins viennent occuper
la terre de votre cours les 19 jeux je
fais en vertu de la loi est ce que vous
êtes d'accord ou disent que c'est ma
propriété mais on dit que la loi
ne reconnaît pas l'acceptent pas la
ceinture
on a le droit de rentrer
la loi respecte le droit historique
quand les américains
sont pas très très content que vous
construisiez des îlots artificiels dans
la région pour pouvoir sécuriser c'est
notre territoire
on a le droit tout faire là dessus
a l'impression de vous faire des ennemis
à faire ça
c'est parce que nos frères ennemis cessé
de défendre nos propres droits et
intérêts légitimes fait pour qu'une
blessure si haut
on défend les intérêts de nos propres
intérêts et le résultat
c'est que il ya des étés pays des gens
qui s'opposent qui s'y opposent qui s'y
opposent qui s'érige en ennemis de la
chine mais alors
rien rien n'y fait n'est ce pas si si
j'adopte si je doute votre
mode de pensée
comment je vais vous percevoir vous les
chinois ont six mois je pense comme vous
et je me dis
on est menacé
les chinois ils sont 1 milliard 400
millions
ils achètent des terres partout il
écoute les câbles sous-marins leurs
entreprises qui vendent des du matériel
informatique
reproduise ce que les états unis ont pu
faire au tout départ en mettant des
portes dérobées
ou de l'intelligence artificielle pour
reconnaître free tibet free démocratie
révolution et des choses comme ça moi je
vais me sentir menacés à la juste
hauteur que vous vous sentez menacés
exact ou pas d'abord ce que vous dites
total tout à l'heure une grande partie
le sont à ce que fait la chine
qu'elle était la grande partie en
question
oui par exemple la porte dérobée la
chine elle ne fait jamais ça se saurait
les américains qui font qu'ils font ça
n'est ce pas laissons les américains de
côté pour l'instant on va s'occuper
l'ordre être pas chez nous répondre à
votre question on doit introduire les
américains parce que là dedans il ya
beaucoup d'éléments qui ôterait qui ont
relations avec les américains pas avec
la chine
donc il faut pas nous accuser
gratuitement
il faut avoir des preuves oui où on nous
accuser de faire des portes dérobées
produisez les preuves
produisait
[Musique]
continuons sur les ressources
comment la chine
voit le pic pétrolier
en ce qui concerne les ressources
oui ou dit que la chine et prédateur est
comment dire et assoiffés d'acheter et
des ressources dans les pays africains
il y a un problème
c'est ce que fait tous les pays
ht et ressources
un peu partout dans le monde
pourquoi les autres pays peuvent le
faire alors quand il s'agit de la chine
c'est une heure c'est une faute
à une erreur
la chine
les les peuples le peuple chinois n'a
pas le droit de vivre de mener une vie
meilleure
la chine et les chinois consomment
beaucoup moins que les américains que
les européens mais pourquoi les chinois
n'ont pas le droit de mener une vie à un
niveau équivalent
l'ine rhji
comment la chine prend conscience du pic
pétrolier pictet pic pétrolier ou pic
pétrolier
le pic pétrolier comment elle modélise
le pic pétrolier la chine ça l'inquiète
s'inquiète pas ouais ouais bien sûr
c'est pourquoi nous développons nos
développeurs et les énergies
renouvelables
renouvela monsieur l'ambassadeur où je
peux vous coupez oui papier
d'aujourd'hui sur 20minutes.fr d'accord
publié aujourd'hui à 17h13 xiaomi au
coeur d'un nouveau scandale sur la
collecte abusive de données via ses
smartphones qui ça guillaumie si on me
oui merci
c'est une nouvelle accusation rouen
c'est une nouvelle accusation aurait
toujours le problème à produisez les
preuves produisez les preuves il faut
pas accuser gratuitement
oui les smartphones ipods sandton est-ce
qu'ils ont des titres ce genre de
problème n'est ce pas est ce que vous
les accusez aux accusés toujours
vous inquiétez pas ici les américains
ils en prennent pour leur grade aussi un
ici ici on est totalement conscient de
l'éventration de notre société par l'eia
femmes ah ouais donc fait très trop le
parallèle avec les américains si nous on
est conscient de ça la milice et c'est
le problème pourquoi où on a puisé pas
les américains mais on vous a puisé
toujours les chinois maintenu
si c'est la même chose on fait pas ça
pourquoi les américains à chaque fois
qu'on les appelle ils avalent leur
salive c'est parce qu'ils sont
totalement conscient qu'on maîtrise leur
dossier et qui savent pertinemment qu'on
a des questions
vraiment vraiment pointu pour laure
démocratie sur la nsa ce que fait la nsa
pourquoi ils écoutent notre président de
la république
pourquoi elle écoute nos journalistes
pourquoi il ya des antennes en eau
d'aero de son ambassade vous inquiétez
pas ils sont totalement au courant que
si on sait il faut pas faire le toujours
le parallèle avec les états unis et si
on est en france on est au courant donc
ils ont aussi pour vous
ouais
le pic pétrolier oui ça vous parle ça
vous parle pas
oui l'hôpital jose 10 pour prévenir
n'est ce pas le pic pétrolier le
gouvernement de la chine s'est
développée depuis longtemps la
technologie de l'énergie renouvelable
l'énergie photovoltaïque
et odien n'est ce pas
la chine est le pays qui ont déployé le
plus
de
d'énergies renouvelables dans le monde
représente à peu près un tiers de la
capacité
d'électricité
verte dans le monde
un petit bout sur le tibet
sur les barrages que vous avez construit
un peu dans la région
pourquoi on peut pas parler du tibet etc
et chinois au
quoi on peut pas parler du tibet avec
les chinois pour bourreau peut on ne
peut pas à parler arrêt 6b les dix
villes du tibet avec griffes y aidera on
peut parler mais cela dépend de quoi
vous parlez
vous parlez de quoi qu'est ce qu'il sous
le développement économique du libé on
me parlait beaucoup
il n'y a pas de problème
oui on les parler de quoi sur le tibet
oui titre moi
qu'est-ce qu'on vous object à chaque
fois entre la chine et le tibet quels
sont les les remontrances occidentales
telles que vous pouvez les percevoir
concernant le tibet qu'est ce qu'on vous
dit vous le tibet la chine la
colonisation du tibet les moines qui se
font taper dessus des choses comme ça
alors le tibet
est une région autonome de la chine le
type et taïwan bien sûr fait partie
intégrante du territoire chinois donc il
n'existe pas une arrivée une distinction
entre le soi disant le tibet et la chine
le tibet fait partie de la chine
alors votre
récit je pense que vous être influencés
énormément par les séparatistes du tibet
alors c'est une petite minorité qui se
sont faits dans les années cinquante
huit derniers siècles
après l'heureux lors des fêtes
de comment dire d'insurrection oui tu es
ou bien des tmt oui ou bien de leurs
mouvements de ses parts à séparatistes
du tibet
donc ce sont leurs aux allégations
taiwan c'est compliqué d'en parler c'est
pas compliqué d'avancer très clair reste
très simple c'est notre vie c'est la
bise ou à taiwan c'est la maison c'est
la base au
csc est une partie inaliénable
du territoire chinois
est-ce que vous menez des opérations
psychologiques à taiwan
une opération psychologique
pourquoi
il n'a pas de mode et d'aider vaincre la
population taiwanaise de retour ni
sereinement dans le giron de la mère
patrie
c'est pas pour convaincre mais
c'est une c'est une réalité
taïwan a jamais séparé de la chine
on ne peut bâtir jamais à pendant les
années les 50 ans avant la fin de la
guerre mondiale taïwan a été occupée par
les japonais
mais c'est après la guerre
sino-japonaise
de
1894 c'est la plus beau coup encore où
je prenais où vous on voulait beaucoup
quand japonais
mais utilisez toujours des mots très
bizarre parce que c'est la guerre entre
la chine et le japon la première guerre
japonais ou fait énormément de massacres
en chine c'est ça c'est ça qui m'a fait
ça c est ce que le mouiller bizarre de
dire vous en voulez encore orléans les
comment comment dire
c'est une crime c'est un crime
de guerre hier vous avez pas compris mon
goût est ce que vous êtes toujours
rancunier ou près du japon
les moines a été pardonné ses moufles et
c'est ouais c'est pas la question de
pardonner les japonais n'ont jamais
reconnu leur crime dans la guerre anti
chinoises oui les politiciens japonais
ont toujours hommage dans le sanctuaire
de yakusuni
way dans ce sanctuaire il y a des trônes
de ddt criminels grillet alors
c'est stimuler la haine ou bien le
souvenir douloureux
du peuple chinois mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que le peuple chinois fasse
rouler que le le peuple chinois pardon a
encore haussé ses criminels ces
guerriers à la rue c'est combien ces
politiciens
non qui sur qui surf sur les courants
nationalistes japonais il faut que les
japonais surtout oui on se comprend que
peut-être la plupart tu peuple japonais
et honnête mais les politiciens
japonais une partie on me dira on ne
peut pas dire tous les politiques une
partie
qui ne veulent pas toujours
comment dire
accepte ou bien reconnaître leurs crimes
carrière dans
la guerre d'invasion agressions anti
chine antichinois ouais
tu es loin après la guerre la première
guerre sino japonaise en 1894 le japon a
occupé la loi mais c'est après la
deuxième guerre mondiale et aussi la
guerre tue peuple chinois de résistance
à l'agression
du japon que la chine a récupéré taïwan
donc depuis la terre revient au giro de
la patrie et fait toujours partie
inaliénable du territoire chinois
et pendant la guerre civile qui suit la
deuxième guerre mondiale
le gouvernement comme hit en est et fait
est sauf se retire sur l'île de taïwan
mais ils n'ont jamais proclamé
l'indépendance de taiwan il considère
toujours taïwan comme une partie
intégrante de la chine
ont ça se passe en gouvernement a encore
très bien maintenant la situation est
très très très favorable très calme et
tout le monde est très content
ici passer un conte
en mines en 2019 il s'est passé des
émeutes
oui
des émeutiers qui casse
qui qui
revendique une certaine liberté c'est
pas certaine liberté c'est l'heure
toujours leurs prix texte
leur but c'est ont revendiqué la soie
dit la soi-disant à dépendance dans con
mais de connivence avec certaines
forces occidentales qu'elles
oui maintenant on veut dire
explicitement les américains
tendues avec les américains en ce moment
et c'est tendu entre vous avec les
américains bret
vous le constatez clairement n'est ce
pas oui c'est pas la chine qui veut une
relation tendue avec les américains nos
éditions nous essayons toujours de
d'avoir une relation de consultation de
coopération de coordination avec les
américains mais ce sont toujours les
américains qui qui provoque qui impose
des problèmes à la chine par exemple la
guerre de commerce la guerre
scientifique technologique
n'est ce pas encore c'est toujours aussi
oui les américains ont beaucoup
dépensé pour us pour un stick et et des
autres le chaos qu'on
laisse aux financiers oui
c'est déjà c'est déjà si je vous propose
avoue ambassadeur loups de venir faire
une
une interview avec l'ambassadeur
américain ici est-ce que vous acceptez
c'est un peu sensible parce que cela
cela entraînerait peut-être été
commandés air des disputes c'est pas
beau ça entraînerait des disputes ici
personne se disputent vous savez
pourquoi personnes se disputent
oui parce qu'ici si les gens disent que
je tape dessus
c'est comme ce que j'ai dit à la chine
souhaite toujours avoir
une relation
comment lire tendre
amicales avec les états unis donc il ne
faut pas
intensifier la tension encore les deux
les relations les deux si je vous
propose de venir discuter avec
l'ambassadeur américain pour échanger
autour des choses que vous aimons jadis
autres on va discuter après après 10
prisé après papa sur papa maintenant on
attend si vous voulez question
d'internet
de damoclès énergie nucléaire en juillet
dernier un réacteur repères de pêche tai
shan dont la france est partenaire
inconnu des fuites de radioactivité
edf a annoncé que six avaient eu lieu en
france le réacteur aurait été arrêté
mais pas en chine pourquoi que s'est il
vraiment passé et je ne suis pas expert
nucléaire a
mais je connais que
la société à l'entreprise chinoise
respecte les règles règlement les
règlements sécuritaire dans le domaine
nucléaire
les règlements internationale s'est pas
uniquement aux chinois donc il au
respect respecter strictement ses
règlements mais peut-être la france a
une approche différente
mais la proche chinoise
est aussi
correct est aussi correct et bien sûr
les deux partis se concertent
après est tombé d'accord sur une
solution c'est beau
question internet
tibet inergie barrage inde la question
le tibet est un bassin énergétique pour
la chine via ses nombreuses centrales
hydroélectriques mais il y également une
source de tensions avec l'inde dont des
millions de personnes dépendent de ces
mêmes flux dont le débit a été modifié
comment la chine compte elle gérer ses
problèmes avec son grand voisin indien
or on reste toujours en consultation
avec les pays voisins sur
les ressources transfrontalières
si la chine construit des barrages sur
la rivière audi
b1 l'or bleu mal aux bleus alors c'est
que la chine a déjà fait une recherche
scientifique exhaustif
pour que cela
n'impacte pas les pays voisins
cela n'impacte pas les intérêts des pays
voisins
c'est après ça que la chine
a construit des barrages alors nous
avons besoin de l'énergie propre n'est
ce pas pour pour répondre au pic
pétrolier
boutique au pic quoique devoir éthique
la clé magique ou bien tout à l'heure où
disait le pic pétrolier le changement
climatique pour
atteindre le pic d'émissions en 2030
n'est ce pas ouais si haut
se départir
ceux des énergies fossiles telles que le
charbon le pétrolier
la chine le peuple chinois ne peut pas
mourir de faim nous devons consommer
toujours l'énergie n'est ce pas alors
d'où vient ce et d'énergie
énergie hydroélectrique
c'est une énergie propre
n'est ce pas donc quand on construit des
barrages aux
ondes tient toujours recompte
des intérêts des préoccupations des
autres pays
question internet guerre taïwan
si la chine ne cherche pas la guerre
pourquoi les intrusions d'avion
militaire dans l'espace aérien talent de
taiwan sont de plus en plus courante est
massive quel est le but
d'abord
taiwan fait partie à des grandeurs de la
china n'est ce pas donc ya pas une
limite pour les avions chinois
ensuite
les autorités taiwan faut toujours
des manoeuvres de provocation pour
défier le principe d'une seule chine
pour mettre en danger
la souveraineté l'intégrité territoriale
de la chine donc l'opération militaire
de l'armée chinoise c'est aussi
une
comment dire
pour
ingo
c'est aussi pour laisser savoir les
autorités taïwanaises qui ne faut pas
franchir la ligne rouge qu'est ce qui se
passe il lire ou j'échange est franchie
qu'est ce qui va se passer la
réunification
de la patrie c'est
s'est défini par la loi de la chine par
la constitution de la chine donc si
quelqu'un
qui fait pour séparer town de la patrie
c'est la ligne rouge
vous on va utiliser tous les moyens le
principal le principe détruire pour
préserver défendre l'intégrité
l'intégralité du territoire principe des
trois guerres
de principe des trois guerres pourquoi
des trois guerres guerre
sur la population bien psychologique et
guerre avec l'arsenal de la lure c'est
toujours
dans le cerveau
tdt chercheurs occidentaux
ils s'imaginent voulu poser que des
questions vous comprenez pourquoi je
vous pose cette question et ouais
pourquoi parce qu'ensuite ils disent des
choses mais nous on veut avoir votre
point de vue sur les choses qui sont
dites puis avec nous en poudre sel la
communication c'est pas une comment dire
les frags aires
séparent les trois guerres c'est à la
position la politique du gouvernement
chinois
je lis la question je vais me faire
l'avocat du diable en chine peut-on dire
librement je souhaite changer de parti
oui voilà alors on peut le dire sans
avoir la police qui vient de 1600 avant
d'autres familles mayence et nous
expliqua en chine là nous avons un parti
au pouvoir
et une parti démocratique en
collaboration avec le parti communiste
chinois s'est pas départi indépendants
ils sont indépendants mais ils sont en
collaboration avec encore baird
coopération avec le parti communiste
chinois et ça c'est les quais de
l'histoire c'est dans les années
40 villes du dernier siècle
c'est parti là
travail est bien heureux avec le parti
communiste chinois pour renverser là le
gouvernement
dicte à terre dugo mi temps donc et
après quant aux renverser ou le commis
tant est créée la république populaire
de chine cette coopération entre le
parti communiste chinois et les huttes
autre parti démocratique continue donc
maintenant on a fait partir la sig
indique je veux changer de bharti pau où
vous pouvez changer vous pouvez changer
de parti a en parti démocratique on
voulait changer tant parti démocratique
a en parti communiste sur internet que
font-ils des chinois qui ne veulent pas
adhérer au projet du pays au projet de
pays du pi a way le projet quel projet
le projet du parti communiste
s'ils sont pas d'accord et il peut être
ne pas d'accord ne doit pas être
d'accord c'est son choix est ce qu'il va
vivre bien sûr bonnes conditions regarde
bien sûr est il déjà idéal tant des
chinois qui travaillaient dans le
secteur privé aucun problème pourquoi
pourquoi chaque fois
que l'on peut discuter avec des chinois
à l'étranger
pour certains ils ont peur de parler
parce qu'ils ont toujours l'idée que
l'oeil de pékin écoute et qu'il pourrait
y avoir des répercussions sur leur
famille restée au pays c'est faux c'est
faux pour c'est une allégation de
certains dissidents
dans les pays occidentaux
écoutez le le le grand frère se trouve
dans certains pays occidentaux rats
c'est pas en chine oui oui avec la
technologie moderne de
d'internet de télécommunication
numérique mais je pense que chacun chez
vous dans les pays occidentaux
peut-être écouter toujours par telle ou
telle personne tel ou tel pays telle ou
telle entreprise
n'est ce pas voir un jour c'est une
expérience personnelle que je vous livre
l'or en avant première
un jour on discutait sur un téléphone
pas sécurisé à régler le problème risque
d'être écouté attendez on l'a fait
exprès
on a téléphoné et qu'un téléphone pas
sécurisé mais équipé d'un petit
programme qui permet de monitorer
l'activité des applications sur le
téléphone
quand on appelait en chine il y avait
des tentatives de prise de photos sur
notre propre téléphone en france prise
de photos terre qui a fait des
tentatives
de prise de photos de nos depuis notre
téléphone de prise de photos de notre
tête
et si les chinois parlent chinois un
signe à cette technologie je pense que
les entreprises occidentales
manipule
beaucoup mieux que les chinois
c'est 8
ccc universelle la sexy parcelles
c'était pas très convaincant oui par
exemple les agences de renseignement des
pays occidentaux
supervise toujours et les personnes des
individus pour tracer les spas les
délinquants les terroristes mais y
compris les dissidents politiques
y compris les citoyens ordinaires n'est
ce pas où on ne me prouve et pamiers
dont je compte seulement les terroristes
mais qui est le terroriste vous savez
une vraie question est est ce que vous
avez passé des accords avec les talibans
pour un avoir accès à leurs ressources
et 2 que les talibans ne viennent pas
exciter les révolutions de type
musulmane chez vous ouais la politique
du gouvernement chinois
sur le changement de l'assiette
situation en afghanistan
résidant en quatre principes
d'abord le taliban doit appliquer une
politique
modérée et
inclusif
voilà
notre politique les talibans doivent
appliquer une ali modéré et
inclusive le gouvernement le
gouvernement taliban vient d'être formé
ya pas une femme mais pas de ministère
défunt n'y a rien du tout toi toi ou
novices doit il doit faire quels sont
les moyens de contrainte
conventionnés là on est allé sur ce
bonheur
c'est du salut une autre chose à
deuxième deuxième principe il faut
essayer de composer un gouvernement
[Musique]
composé de différentes
forces n'est ce pas
et troisièmement il faut couper et dhien
avec les organisations terroristes
y compris les terroristes
fille cynthia
qu'il dit et rosine genou s'est joint la
boue le mouvement ce qu'il soit disant
tu diot qui ce dieu qui ce temps
orientales ce qui pourrait être
considéré avec un autre prisme de
lecture comme des résistants qui veulent
leur indépendance ils sont sept cette
organisation terroriste est listée au
sécurité au conseil de sécurité que le
t2t nations-unies ce que la chine a
quatrième point quatrième point
talibans doit
mener vient entretenir de bonnes
relations avec les pays voisins
et
sur ces principes là le coup allemand
chinois développer des relations avec le
taliban
si les taliban qui continuent à tabasser
leurs femmes alors m des burqa partout
alors interdire de d'étudier plus que de
raison alors alors à les traiter comme
des sous-hommes est ce que la chine
qui a des femmes très très puissante
va tolérer
qu'il se comporte comme au xiiie siècle
j'ai déjà exprimé la position chinoise
j'ai déjà exprimées si vous voulez que
j'ai dit et je répète toujours heures
les positions sinon c'est de ma faute
j'ai mal posé une question
quels vont être vos mesures de pression
sur des talibans
6 il nous ne tiennent pas des bons
rapports intérieur et extérieur
jeu tout à l'heure tout d'abord la chine
n'impose pas comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure n'est ce pas on ne fait pas la
pression alors se sont voulus par
souvent l'impression se sont toujours
le peuple
d'un pays qui décident les affaires de
ce pays là donc
quelle politique
adopter
cela dépend du peuple de ce pays là et
en tant que pays étrangers nous pouvons
exprimer notre position de principe
chaque pays a le droit
d'exprimer leurs propres positions n'est
ce pas la france aussi la chine rossi
sait c'est le cas oui on a déjà exprimé
notre position
question internet où on est le projet de
monnaie chinoise basé sur l'or voilà sur
quoi lors
je ne connais pas
les crypto menez vous pouvez nous en
dire quoi l'élu pincus et bah oui la
banque centrale de la chine a commencé
dès des
expérimentés
expérimentation de la monnaie numérique
gemppi oui on a fait
les essais
il est en train dans le processus
evergrande ça vous parle quand quoi
evergrande et
evergrande
une sous city j'ai fait venir ngwe
grande oui c'est une société immobilier
ils rencontrent des difficultés
il est sûr en dd c'est le problème ouais
faut avoir un crédit social tous pourris
lui crédit social
excuse tous les dirigeants c'est cet
hiver en a je pense que c'est long par
rapport à la gravité de leurs problèmes
le crédit social
s'est passé par un problème on ne parle
pas de ça maintenant pour le moment où
on s'inquiète
de ce que comment on résoudre leurs
difficultés et entêtement c'est le
problème c'est 265 milliards wyeth après
at après le reportage
j'ai assez énorme est ce que la chine a
fonctionné un petit peu comme l'espagne
pour maintenir une croissance
sponsorisé par le l'immobilier en
construisant à tout va tout va tout va
d'ailleurs la plupart du temps d'une
façon très pourri
avec des villes fantômes
uniquement pour stimuler son économie
d'une façon artificielle comme a pu le
faire l'espagne oui il ya quelques
années
dans la presse occidentale
on parlait des villes fantômes on a
construit beaucoup d'immeubles il n'y a
pas beaucoup de gens qui habitaient
mais récemment j'ai lu des reportages en
chine il dit que ces villes là
maintenant c'est déjà en
vivacité donc les habitants sont plus en
plus nombreux dans ses villas donc il y
a en quoi une
un point là dedans pour bien comprendre
le développement de la chine
la construction des infrastructures
oui il faut être un peu plus à avancer à
l'avance
expliqué 265 milliards d'endettement sur
une société chinoise oui c'est énorme
que vous vous l'expliquer
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas expert de
ce domaine
je n'ai pas de connaissances
spécial pour expliquer ce phénomène vous
pouvez m'expliquer les lois concernant
les faillites en chine et les lois je ne
connais pas beaucoup à et il y avait des
faillites et mais pas beaucoup en chine
cela mais je suis sûr à j'ai la
conviction sur le gouvernement chinois
bien traiter ce problème bien résoudre
le problème
question internet mais où et jacquemin
je ne connais pas je
ne suis pas son proche
je ne connais pas qui c'est vous voyez
qui sait je connais qui sait je tendais
qui s'est battu le nom
pourquoi il a disparu jacques il a
disparu entre le puy me paraît qu'il ya
quelques jours il a apparu dans la
presse chinoise il avait l'air mieux riz
du kick avons-nous
nos
cesser votre allégation est mieux mieux
réitérée du qui parce que cette saison
des rumeurs si des rumeurs je pense à je
vous pose et que je pensais pas je ne
connais pas non plus à ce que lui
reprochent les rumeurs qui traînent ici
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a fait venir
pour éclaircir ces rumeurs selon votre
prisme de lecture les rumeurs c'est que
le parti communiste lui a expliqué un
petit peu que il contribuait pas assez
et que et qu ils habitent il a été mis
pente il a été mis pendant trois ans
alors salon acs être de ces allégations
se ressent vraiment très ridicule c'est
ridicule ridicule
est ce que le parti communiste a décidé
de remettre au pas son indice truies sur
l'industrie de la texture s est toujours
d'aider précis des allégations dans la
presse occidentale mettre au pas comme
ça c'est pas comme ça ce pli qui nous
oui
c'est ridicule c'est la régulation du
marché c'est pour lutter contre le
monopole du marché et la concurrence
déloyale
ce sont des mesures de régulation
appliquée par tous les pays du monde
oui pour
réguler les géants du numérique chez ou
n'est ce pas la même chose
vous imposer des amendes de gigantesques
rocha femmes
riches femmes au congo et oui les prix a
écopé d'une amende de plusieurs
centaines de millions de ses fleurons en
seria sérieux il faut combien d'argent
par jour chez nous ok c'est rien c'est
pas grand chose par rapport à leur
chiffre d'affaires
mais c'est quand même une mesure de
régulation n'est ce pas question
internet un ordinateur quantique chinois
un réseau l'udc ont seulement 4,2 eur un
calcul qui durerait des milliers
d'années sur un ordinateur classique
j'ai pas bien saisi cette question où
est ce que vous en êtes avec
l'ordinateur quantique quantico ouais
ouais je connais je connais des
ordinateurs tandis que la chine est en
train de
faire la recherche qu'est ce qu'on peut
ouais j'ai l'impression qu'on tombe du
pape a parlé de l'ordinateur quantique
la cote
c koi l'ordinateur quantique
je connais seulement cette nation mais
je pense que c'est une technologie très
avancée à très avancé à quoi ça sert
c'est bien pour accélérer la vitesse de
capture et je pense
donc grâce à ça il peut casser du
chiffrement
connaissez le chiffrement non la
cryptologie créé par la crypte horloge
cryptée cryptée un message avec le
cantique on peut casser donc peut-être
vous utilisez un téléphone sécurisé
téléphone de téléphones sécurisés vous
avez quoi comme téléphonant non non non
quelles sont les mesures de sécurité à
l'ambassade de chine en france très bien
loti pas très bonnes réponses est-ce que
vous avez quelqu'un qui s'occupe de la
secte falun gong dans votre ambassade
il ya quelqu'un dans votre ambassade qui
qui valent encore et est déclarée pour
par le gouvernement chinois comme
insectes est ce que dans votre merdier
quelqu'un qui est là pour surveiller ce
qui se passe en france avec le falun
gong on n'est pas des informations à
fournir
sous la torture
question à internet
je vous en attrape une tout de suite y
at il une alternative au parti
communiste en chine
le parti communiste chinois
à
un engagement initial
devrait au renouveau de la nation
chinoise et au bonheur
par quels moyens ce fut la course de
badié et le parti communiste chinois et
le choix de l'histoire et le choix du
peuple chinois
donc il est le pilier ou bien
comment dire
le pilier de réaliser le renouveau de la
nation chinoise
et de bien servir le peuple serbe
chinois s'il n'y arrive pas il arrivera
s'il n'y arrive pas et larry bras
j'ai quand même réussi à avoir un
sourire
et
donc question internet par quels moyens
ce fait la consultation de la population
quel est le mode de consultation de la
population par dotation enquête çà çà
doute une question qui ne sait vraiment
c'est vraiment eu une approche très très
réussie en chine à la consultation
populaire populaire oui comme je vous ai
présenté tout à l'heure nous applique
aux une démocratie de tout processus ça
veut dire avant de prendre les décisions
on consulte la population
consultée leurs avis leurs propositions
comme ça
alors on applique cette proposition a de
différents niveaux est différente
manière
on peut dire que la consultation se
trouvent partout dans la politique aux
biens dans la gestion sociale en chine
par exemple nous avons un système
du parti politique qui s'appelle la
conférence de consultation politique du
peuple chinois
cette conférence se trouve à tous les
niveaux du couvert de l'administration
de la chine au plus niveau c'est au
niveau de l'état et au niveau provincial
au niveau municipal
il existe toujours cette conférence de
consultation politique du peuple chinois
je vais essayer de faire une diversion
c'est difficile de home avait prévenu
que les chinois qui étaient en occident
c'était les meilleurs des meilleurs
parce qu'ils sont 1 milliard 400
millions et que s'ils se retrouvent là
c'est qu'ils soient soient sont très
très bien loyaux au parti soit c'est les
meilleurs des meilleurs
est un diplomate difficile à faire
pareil aux questions internet
je vous propose une question flatteuse
pour monsieur lellouche et si la chine
était la première puissance mondiale
dans tous les domaines quelle vision du
monde souhaiterait souhaiterait tel
partager avec la communauté
internationale
c'est la communauté de destin partagé de
l'humanité c'est notre objectif pour
pour comment dire à l'avenir du monde
alors quelle sera cette communauté de
destin partagé c'est la paix n'est ce
pas le développement et la rue la riche
la prospérité commune l'harmonie et
l'environnement
eau et
donc ya pas de guerre il n'y a pas de
conflit oui
je fais bien du courage question
internet les résultats de l'enfant
unique petit l'on parle y
petit rond par les eaux en parle
toujours de ceux de sète ce problème
mais maintenant on a déjà révoqué cette
politique depuis plusieurs années
maintenant le coup le gouvernement
encourage que les couples jeunes fait
trois enfants
un bugdroid le gouvenement faut ni des
dead way pour les encourager qu'est ce
que c'est la branche et sully la broche
quoi et sully
c'est les chinois qui viennent au
vietnam acheter leurs femmes parce qu'il
trouvent pas assez de femmes en chine
ouais à vrai dire je ne connais pas très
bien ce genre de problème
question d'internet un mot sur le guen
numérique cette monnaie numérique doit
est donc centrale couplera très bien les
plus crédit social pour contrôler les
finances des sites web
ouais alors le lien numérique
à sa vocation
très
diversifiés multiplier
mais je remarque que certaines personnes
se concentrait toujours
le soi-disant crédit est comment dire
très peu en france ça fait très très
peur parce qu'on a peur que le
gouvernement français s'inspire du
gouvernement chinois vous pouvez
demander le gouvernement français de ne
pas s'inspirer du gouvernement chinois
inventé on a inventé un truc pour ça
vous avez inventé la poudre nous avons
fait le guillotiner mais c'est pas c'est
pas notre offre votre forte commenté l
apôtre
plus d'enfants
question internet
est-ce que vous respectez la parole
comme un australien
est ce que vous respectez votre parole
comme l'australie ma parole ah ouais
ouais allez il vous respectez votre
parole commune australiens comme un
faussaire pourquoi comme parce que les
australiens resterai toujours comme nous
mêmes
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
sous-marins français du dîner et
l'instabilité de nos régions c'est ça
c'est une menace
à la stabilité de la région
pourquoi
d'abord la chine parce que ça contient
chine parce que cela stimulera accents
dur à la course aux armements nucléaires
dans la région
l'australie est un pays non nucléaires
donc il ne faut pas proliférer
la technologie nucléaire à un pays non
nucléaires
s'est défini par une convention
internationale
alors les états unis le royaume uni le
faut comme ça
c'est
contrevenir
ouvertement
aux règles internationales de non
prolifération
ouais
donc nous pouvons nous sous marins l'un
d'eux ça va hein on peut vendre des
sous-marins à l'inde
ces deux puissances nucléaires love
we donc cela cela débat cela il y à des
experts pour étudier ce genre de
problème oui il ya des experts de
deux contrôles d'armement international
tu quittes xts qui discutent
question internet qu'est ce qu'il pense
du détournement de propriété l'actuel
effectué par la filière chinoise arm
arm vous savez ici c'est une filiale qui
se comporte comme s'il était indépendant
de la maison mère
ces vols qui vole en fait du savoir
faire de la maison
je ne comprends pas
rmc est une société arm
ase à
rmc c'est une entreprise israël non ça
va ou verra ça plus tard quelle est la
relation que la chine a avec le vietnam
en mer de chine
oui il existe des des divergences des
litiges entre les deux pays
dans cette région là mais les dirigeants
des deux pays sont d'accord de mettre de
côté notre divergence pour trouver un
terrain d'entente
pour développer pour poursuivre ensemble
le développement
des économique de notre pays
et où connaissez les deux pays
entretiennent de bonnes relations
bilatérales
les deux pays sont gouvernés
tous les deux par le parc dans le in
east donc nous avons le le même idéal la
même convention la même philosophie
on peut là l'afrique où vous avez passé
des années
on voit souvent
peut-être que c'est pas représentatif de
la réalité sur le terrain mais on voit
souvent des patrons chinois en afrique
mal se comporter avec les africains
et maintenant vos les africains
relever la tête et dire aux chinois ça
suffit vous arrêtez d'une traités comme
des esclaves
et des fois ça se termine au point mais
ça se termine au point comme en afrique
que nous faisons en se tapant dessus
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas est-ce
que c'est pas toujours le cas je pense
que même si il existe ce cas c'est très
peu s'est isolée pour
tous les pays il ya des gens des gens
peau des gens mauvais n'est ce pas
qu'ils se comportent différemment t&t
voyous
en afrique mais cela ne représente pas
l'ensemble
des chinois
les ouigours
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
nous nous on entend way que le parti
communiste se comporte d'une façon
très difficile à concevoir avec nos
valeurs occidentales
qu'est ce qu'on fait cette minorité qui
turcophone alors tout d'abord cette
minorité n'est pas dieu qu phone
c'est une lettre ni où ils courent n'est
pas l'ethnie turc c'est tout à fait
différent ouais
et ensuite
la minorité
ouïghoure
vivent maintenant très bien en chine
c'est parce qu'il nous est décrit
moi si je devais résumer trivialement ce
que nous nous décrit ses ils vivent
comme des gens ont pays oui c'est tout à
fait contraire
c'est tout à fait contraire
il y a des années là bas il y avait des
attaques des multiples des innombrables
attaques terroristes violent et alors le
gouvernement chinois a pris des mesures
pour lutter contre le terrorisme
et
réaliser la sécurité est depuis plus de
quatre euros il ne s'est plus passé tu
attaques terroristes
mais l'été particulier c'est une bonne
chose pour la population locale pour
l'ethnie oui cours parce que tout le
monde peut vivre tranquillement
apaisement lille peuvent sortir dans la
nuit oui le marché nocturne
souffre rossouw de nouveau se réouvre
serez our way
c'est pas beau jeu j'en sais rien j'ai
pas eu tant qu'on voit donc on re sauver
seulement des informations de la presse
est ici non mais vous n'êtes pas au
courant dès que le pays va réouvrir vous
allez me faire un visa oui bien sûr
après la après la bande amy est
comment dire je conseille et de talent
est vraiment en chine au cimetière pour
voir devant prendre mieux nous nous
abreuve de documentaires
vrai ou pas vrai telle est votre regard
où les ouigours sont sinueuses et de
force
c'est encore où sont ils sont rééduquer
de force
oui quelles preuves
on va aller chercher vos vins qui
dépensent way est ce que maintenant vous
avez les preuves pour que tu me soutenir
nommée par les nations compte je vous
mettrai sur votre compte twitter
les dossiers qu'on a pu faire sur un
rêve
l'ambassade de chine à a publié
plusieurs articles pour faire des
d'éclaircissement qui part qui écrit
parlant parce que le personnel de
l'ambassade pour faire etc les ratios
faire des explications pour mettre à nu
tous ces mensonges effectué ce sur le
soutien qui si vous êtes intéressé je
peux vous fournir ces attitudes nom
n'est pas du genre à récupérer les
informations mais on est des nous on est
des loups chasseurs
et nous on aime chasser même la traque
prêt ou nem l'embuscade et on aime les
pistes on n'aime pas se voir on appelle
ça du ps ont choisi ici on n'avait pas
on n'aimait pas les articles de
l'ambassade
mais les informations fournies par la
presse ici le monde parce que ce n'est
pas ce que vous chassez vous mêmes nous
va chasser sur leurs terres
voyez qui font pas correctement et donc
y fort il faut observer une attitude
objective est-ce que vous garantissez
d'avoir un visa point je ne peux pas
vous garantir
mais je peux faire de mes efforts pour
ont procuré le visa je ne peux pas ou
garantir que vous aurez certainement le
visa parce que comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la délivre réseau de visa relève
de la souveraineté d'un pays
occupé une question le gouvernement d'un
pays a le droit de délivrer ou pas
envisager cela dit cela ne dépend pas de
moi mais du que des votes pays ouvrent
ont dès que votre pays rivaux et aig
je vous donnerai après la pandémie les
mesures de rsa ni terre sera un peu
comment dire
élargi
on peut avoir plus de possibilités
de délivrer des visas aux étrangers 20
touristique
ça dépend où on ne peut pas prévoir
comment dire les choses
des années on vient des mois ou bien des
années après avec la pandémie face b
dont les années saison le gouvernement
prend des mesures des politiques
toujours
en vertu de la situation
la situation sanitaire et d'autres
questions internet un président un vice
a existe dans une démocratie
je répète ma question un président à vie
ça existe dans une démocratie magie
ghazi avis
aj avis advitam eternam
je suis jusque jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
est ce que vous imaginez emmanuel macron
président jusqu'à 89 ans
à aller je répète ma question un
président à alger ou bien à vis à vis à
vis à vis
à excuser moi ouais c'est de ma faute un
président à vie c'est difficile de
parler avec le masque c'est ça existe
dans une démocratie
au président le chef d'état est ce qu'un
président élu à vie le président est un
chef d'état n'est ce pas d'accord mais à
vie ça existe ça je décris dans une
démocratie le royaume uni
le chef d'état
a déjà vu les camps du oui gourong déjà
parlé on va aller voir sur place
est-ce que vous avez des questions
abordées avec nous
non oh j'ai déjà trop de questions à
répondre
qu'est ce que vous garderez comme
sentiment des français
sentiments oui
effectivement
j'ai que je garde un sentiment très
comment dire très amicale avec les
français j'ai beaucoup d'amis français
ici
vous résumeriez avec votre perception
votre histoire que vous pouvez résumé un
français si vous deviez décrire la
france et les français aux chinois en
chine où ni comment voyez vous les
disciplines et où les
le français quand j'étais écrit en
français n'est ce pas
je pense que le français est très comme
pour la plupart des chinois tcl
romantique près ces enthousiastes
et ils savoir bien la vie vraie a un
goût très très élégant de la vie
et la france est un pays développé
aussi sur eux le plan économique mais
aussi mais que sur le plan culturel et
les chinois aiment bien la culture
française
la peinture la musique les musées ici
farmer e line farmer farmer nos c'est
une artiste française
et ils ont très très fameux wii question
internet lemaitre 10 3 sorte d'ami sont
utiles trois sortes d'amis sont néfastes
les utile un ami droit fsu ce qu'il a
dit un ami fidèle un ami cultiver les
néfastes un ami fou un à limoux oui
alibaba c'est un ami c'est un ami
français ben je ne sais pas si tu es un
français ou bien chinois ye connaît bien
lâche la culture en chine est ce que la
france et la chine sont debout et demi
ouais nous sommes bons amis la chine
considère toujours la france comme notre
l'autre ami
la plus la plus prioritaire
notre traditionnel amis traditionnels
parce que la france est le premier pays
occidental à établir les relations
diplomatiques avec la chine et on
considère la france comme notre non
seulement amis mais notre partenaire
stratégique et globale
donc 7 1 c'est une définition de très
haut niveau
vis-à-vis d'un pays étranger ça veut
dire la chine veut faire tout pour
faire la coopération avec la france sur
tous les problèmes sur tous les sujets
du monde oui mais aussi sur la
coopération bilatérale
question peut-être que vous n'avez pas
pouvoir répondre le problème de
l'endettement de du monténégro et la
position de la chine sur ce dossier
et je ne connais pas très bien ce
problème j'ai suivi seulement des
reportages dans la presse ici il me
paraît que le monténégro ce pays à
emprunter de l'argent
au point que chinoises pour construire
une autoroute ce n'est ce pas c'est ce
projet là
n'est ce pas il ya de fortes chances oui
oui vous ne connaissez pas non plus
je ne connais pas les détails de ce
projet mais en principe
ce projet de l'autoroute est très utile
pour le pays parce que le pays d'auch le
pilier industriel de celle tourisme
alors cette autoroute une fois construit
favorisera
largement le développement du tourisme
et où le fait que les chinois rachètent
des aéroports puis après les met en
faillite en ayant bien sûr je suis
quelques subventions locales au ca en
france en france quelque l aéroport on
s'est fait transiter par les chinois
j'ai un trou dimanche demandant des
communautés elle va nous dire ça tout de
suite
donc ça n'existe plus des chinois qui
qu'un v6 à l'étranger pour pressurer
jusqu'à la dernière goutte et puis
ensuite sans
diaboliser à interpol isation des
questions internet est ce que la chine
continue de construire des nouvelles
centrales à charbon
hier
le président 6e pied a déclaré dans son
discours à l'onu en
visio à en virtuel il a déclaré que la
chine
restera la construction de centrales à
charbon
à l'étranger en chine en chine
on va arrêter progressivement
parce que le développement économique a
besoin encore de l'électricité n'est ce
pas où vous avez
l'électricité produit 2
à charbon représente en gros ce 50 % à
peu près si on supprime
si on supprime à 7 par cette partie
d'électricité alors l'économie chinoise
va s'effondrer n'est ce pas
précédente question si l'aéroport de
toulouse blagnac oui c'est pas le cas
que vous vous décris vous décrivez
d'après ce que je sais
on avait des investisseurs chinois a
acheté la
la manipulation ménagement ou de la
gestion de l'aéroport de toulouse qui a
rencontré des difficultés financières
et trois ans pendant trois ans de la
gestion
l'aéroport
remonte donc accueilli accueilli
beaucoup plus de passagers death par
aileurs le
tonnage de fret
augmente aussi
et
en ce temps là les habitants locaux se
lève pour s'opposer et d'ailleurs
l'entreprise a payé des impôts au
gouvernement
local et jésus mention aussi nous c'est
pas subventions c'est un c'est un
investisseur privé je pense de la chine
c'est pas une entreprise d'état donc les
habitants s'y opposent alors alors le
gouvernement français demande
l'entregent l'investisseur chinois tu te
quitter de se retirer
et je ne sais pas quel est le résultat
il me paraît que l'investisseur chinois
se retire ce
est obligé
pourquoi la chine ne respecte pas le
jugement de la cour permanente
d'arbitrage de la haye sur les zizou sur
les îles ou qu'elle a illégalement
militarisé c'est pas la cour c'est
ce qu'a conclu gauche connaît c'est le
procès
avancés par les philippines
c'est un projet d'arbitrage
arbitrage alors vous connaissez bien
dans le cas de l'arbitrage il faut avoir
l'accord des deux parties concernées
la chine n'est pas d'accord de de
s'ingérer ou bien
d'accepter cet arbitrage parce que selon
la convention des nations unies sur la
mer
quand il s'agit du litige du territoire
les pays
ne peut pas accepter l'arbitrage et est
d'ailleurs la chine le gouvernement
chinois gandil le signer la convention
il a exprimé la réservation que
quand il s'agit des litiges et
territoriales la chine
préconise la solution par voie
bilatérale
donc on n'a pas accepté l'arbitrage le
le verdict de cette
soi disant cour n'a pas d'effet jeu
judiciaire
question internet que pense-t-il de la
guerre hors limites
conceptualisé par le colonel chine ou
inquiet au young et wang yukui
excusé je ne connais pas cet ouvrage de
du même nom publié en 1999 4
1 ouvrage est à littéraire un extrait le
résultat c'est que tout en réduisant
l'espace du champ de bataille nous
continuons à nous battre n piller et
nous massacrer comme par le passé les
armes sont plus modernes les moyens plus
sophistiqués il ya seulement un peu
moins de 100 mais tout autant de
brutalité face à cette réalité le rêve
de la paix de l'humanité reste aussi
incertain et lointain qu'auparavant
voilà je ne connais pas des oeuvres
littéraires ou bien de recherche
c'est énorme
aussi en chine que dans les pays
occidentaux
question sur les relations chine durant
l'ère de trump est ce que vous avez
entendu le fait que les généraux chinois
avaient été en contact avec les généraux
américains pendant la transition parce
que les généraux américains avaient peur
que les chinois pensent que trump allait
déclencher la guerre je ne connais pas
là cette affaire là mais j'ai vu dans le
reportage de la presse américain il y à
quoi un livre nouvellement
sorti raconte
cette affaire
je ne connais pas si c'est vrai ou pas
question internet pourquoi le lanceur d
alerte sur le colis de 19 a été arrêté
et mis sous soumis au silence question
de l'epa q
je connais
qui te qui il parle c'est le docteur
roger ouégnin le tordeur d'ionia n'est
pas lanceur alerte il n'est pas un
médecin épidémiologiste
épidémiologistes il est un
ophtalmo logique
ophtalmologiques
à auzat en dalmau log donc
c'est pas lui qui a tiré la l'alertent
c'est un autre médecin épidémiologiste
qui s'appelle madame d'indiens qui a
contacté le premier
se coronavirus le 27 décembre 2019 il a
tout de suite rapporté à ses supérieurs
et
les autorités de différents niveaux à
des sites et peut-être halles à la fin
de l'année le 30 décembre al hal a
affiché une annonce intérieur sur le
système sanitaire et hôpital hospitalier
pour pour qu' il faut faire attention ce
nouveau rue puis russe mais à ce temps
là personne ne connaît pas qu'elle est
c'est pas une raison pour lui vous les
flics 1 c'est pas une raison pour lui
envoyer la police non atteint
et ce capteur 10 millions connaît oui
cette information il a il a fait
connaître cette information à ses amis
dans le widget mais il a dit qu alors
c'est une information interne urvoas et
pas encore retrait
final donc il faut pas le diffuser alors
ce sont des amis là qui ont diffusé et à
ce temps là à vrai dire
l'information n'est pas encore défini
donc on
connaissait bien
il faut pas diffuser des informations
imprécises pour ne pas créer d d d peur
la peur dans la population
et la police
lamit pour interpellé et du dire que il
faut pas comme ça de près et le lot le
faire le laisser rentrer à la maison on
n'a pas l'arrêter tout d'abord on n'a
pas l'arrêter il continuer à travailler
dans l'hôpital il continue et et après
il est contaminé dans son travail il est
un
ophtalmologiste allemand maroc il est
contaminé et malheureusement
[Musique]
il n'a pas être réussir à être guéri il
a était mort donc
à vrai dire il n'est pas un
as lecteurs
comment dire seul blu ray rice aux
pleurs tireur alerte un tir oeuvres
d'alain jean louis zome l'heure il n'est
pas ça
pour vous
oui pour la chine oui je connais des
oxydants veulent coller une étiquette
ouais
si on parle des ruisseaux pleurs aux
américains ils y attendait au hip hop
leur qui sont malmenés
est-ce que vous accordiez est ce qu est
ce qu dans un monde parfait
il doit le jeune julian assange pourrait
demander l'asile à la chine l'avis
demandé quoi l'asile l'asile non je ne
suis pas au courant est ce que ça
pourrait se faire est ce que la chine
voudrait bien accorder l'asile
à songe où elle nous donne
c'est une supposition
n'est ce pas c'est une éventualité
acceptable
c'est il m'est difficile de te donner
une 1h réponses très précises
je ne suis pas dans ce domaine je ne
suis pas expert question internet human
rights watch accuse la chine de crimes
contre l'humanité il en pense quoi
qu'at-il à dire sur les quatre géants du
textile don unique loup index marque
zara
murail from rights watch
human right watch valley c'est une
organisation anti chinoises ouais non
mais ils sont pas qu antichi loin ouais
pourquoi on dit de cette année
antichinois et pourquoi on discute que
si la recette une organisation anti
chinoises c'est que toutes ces
accusations contre la chine ce sont 1
crédible un crédible et viable
incroyable et dénuées de fondement
dénuées de fondement en général quand
même les toits qu'ils ont ce matin à
vrai dire le gouvernement chinois ne
veut pas même de se donner la peine
d'aller répondre alors si vous lui
répondez pas est ce que vous lisez vous
allez les états qui auront fait
l'explication dans la presse d'accord
mais c'est sur la question son
cellulaire la situation chinoise
d'accord mais imaginez vous avez une
organisation qui vous accusent
de crimes contre l'humanité on n'a rien
au fait des explications est ce que vous
allez les malteries sda comme les
explications 525 minutes d'après ce que
j'ai compris est ce que vous allez
poursuivre en justice si vous estimez
que c'est fou
on connaissait la justice est toujours
très très compliqué n'est ce pas surtout
vous faudrait surtout dans les pays
occidentaux
chez vous c'est plus simple justice
c'est autre chose
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est déjà une
organisation qu'on tout le monde connaît
il est il est voué à la vocation
de se comporter ou à agir contre la
shiver on n'a pas la peine
de passer le temps de dépenser des
salive avec lui
le fait d'avoir interdit le jeu vidéo
plus de trois heures par semaine ou à la
jeunesse oui
c'est c'est une bonne chose pour les
enfants et les parents parce que les
parents
préventif que depuis longtemps que leurs
enfants ne dépense pas tout le temps
dans le vide et au delà dans le jeu
vidéo il faut dépenser
le temps dans l'étude dans le sport dans
la musique
c'est ma peau c'est une bonne chose
est ce qu est ce que vous pouvez nous
confier trois livres
au moins je peux vous conseiller un
livre écrit par maxime vivas le titre
c'est oui cours en finir avec les faits
news
oui c'est un très beau livre je vous
conseille de le lire c'est un petit
livre qui n'est pas très épais très
facile à lire
12 outre d'un des autres il y a encore
un livre qui est qui qui vient de sortir
comment dire
qui est qui qui raconte
la chine
écrit par utah dizaine d'auteurs de
différents pays du monde il y a de la
france de l'australie et d'autres pays
j'ai oublié le nom le titre de ce livre
là mais c'est très c'est un livre très
beau aussi
édition vous en plus par l'état tels cas
oui et il y a encore un livre que j'ai
pas lu mais je connais ce livre l'art
qui raconte le cimetière oui écrit aussi
parer une équi écrivain française
suivent l écrivaine
durée crayon shin chan oui oui
donc pourquoi je
cite si livre là parce que je pense que
c'est sur ce sujet là que les français
n'ont pas beaucoup de l'information
crédible ou des informations que vous
avez rassemblé brute
oui je raconte aussi à jet de fournir
aussi les informations question internet
la mafia chinoise quelles relations avec
le parti communiste mafia pourquoi mafia
les triades pour voir pourquoi mafia la
mafia chinoise est ce qui vous avait
encore de la mafia chéneaux et puis d'un
chien non
alors question bonsoir que pense-t-il
les ingénieurs nucléaires breton qui
découvre ou redécouvre l'amour aux côtés
des jeunes femmes chinoises
à gênés aux protons
nucléaire breton away sous-marin île
longue des trucs comme ça quoi ouais
question de l'âge la repousse pourquoi
bonjour que pense-t-il des ingénieurs
nucléaires breton bon français
qui découvre ou redécouvre l'amour aux
côtés de jeunes femmes chinoises
vous a parlé au début
je n'arrive pas à répondre à ce genre de
problème
la question
énergie russie quelles sont vos
relations en matière d'énergie avec la
russie comment ont-elles évolué ces
dernières années et route de la soie
pakistan où en est le projet de nouvelle
route de la soie à elle connu un coup
d'arrêt à cause du coc vide où sont les
travaux au pakistan et le nouveau canal
en amérique du sud aux
trois questions est-ce mal les relations
entre la chine et la russie est
excellente on va dire maintenant les
deux pays sont partenaires sera d'agir
que de coordination
et je pense que il ya aucun problème
dans les relations bilatérales entre nos
deux pays et cet
élément
stabilité de stabilité
dans las dans la seine
dans la situation internationale
le projet de la construction de
l'initiative ceinturé route au pakistan
marche assez bien à chasser viendrait
même si récemment sonné perturbé par des
attaques terroristes
mais quand même les deux pays la chine
et le pakistan sont déterminés à mener à
bien abou les projets de construction et
ça est dans l'intérêt des deux pays par
exemple un projet de 2,2 de deux
centrales wall a fourni un tiers
d'électricité du pays donc cela améliore
beaucoup
l'environnement d'investissement et la
vie populaire de ce pays
en ce qui concerne le canal en amérique
latine n'est ce pas je ne connais pas
est ce que
monsieur
sur le canal le deuxième canal de
panama n'est ce pas
j'ai entendu dire j'ai entendu dire
alger mais je n'ai pas connu et la suite
peut-être c'est encore rester sur le
plan oui ou bien sûr l'idée question
internet arm est une entreprise
britannique de semi conducteurs donc arm
alfa romeo mike hockey arm à css et la
quasi totale à la responsable
est une entreprise britannique de semi
conducteurs leurs architectures de
processeurs récemment utilisé sur les pc
et systems and chips d'apple les aimera
cheaps donc les la filiale chinoise arm
a coupé les ponts avec la maison mère
britannique est ce que la chine prévoit
d'agir dans cette affaire pour punir le
comportement dans l'entreprise chinoise
afin de garder de bonnes relations
internationales ou bien se garde tel
d'intervenir car cette propriété
intellectuelle représente une
opportunité financière
considérable à vrai dire je ne connais
pas beaucoup sur sur cette affaire là
on va arriver à la fin notre interview
parce que ça déjà longtemps qu'on
discute et vous vous rendez pas compte
le nombre de questions pour son corps je
ne connais pas c'est cette affaire c'est
trop compliqué être trop comme à dire
professional est ce pas donc on arrive à
la fin notre interview est-ce que vous
avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
quelque chose bouteille à la mer
quelque chose qui restera sur les
réseaux nouvelle gêne des jeunes
générations un conseil un conseil pour
les jeunes générations de quel pays on
vient pas de nous tous et toutes et tous
alors
pour les les jeunes générations je pense
que l'avenir du monde réside
temps eux et il est important
qu'il
prend l'étude des connaissances
différents pays parce que le monde de
demain sera un monde
globalisé oui tous les pays tous les
nations tous les peuples sont liés
l'un à l'autre donc il est important de
ne pas se coincer dans leur propre pays
et de ne pas se coincer dans leur propre
idéologie il faut être ouvert il faut
souffre à d'autres pays et d'autres
cultures d'autres civilisations
pour reconstruire
ensemble un monde meilleur de demain
question internet 2 c'est pas pour
terminer votre question sociale van
houtte qui lui mange bien je le fais
l'allocution la chine a construit le
siège de l'union africaine
or la cl quoi de l'union africaine et à
la csg d'alénya or les informations d
ont été découvertes en 2017 que
l'intégralité du contenu de ces serveurs
étaient transférés à shanghaï la chine
cache-t-elle des informations c'est déjà
des démentis des ventes il était midi
par les la part de l'union africaine et
des pays africains
j'ai tellement honte
merci pour ce conseil aux jeunes
défavorisés c'est bien très c'est très
excitant que si vous soniques vous avez
fait 3h29 d'interview ouais 3h30 ah
ouais oh
je ne sais pas c'est impossible
pourquoi c'est impossible ces sept rôles
au sénat se tenir est-ce que vous avez
vu le temps passer j'ai pas j'ai pas vu
les pas senti j'ai pas sentiers le temps
passe et ambassadeur du chili merci dans
un prix très bien très content
[Musique]